All right,
here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
How are you man?
What's going on?
Gel?
I'm stuck,
man.
I'm really good.
Really glad to be here.
I'm stoked too.
Yeah.
Nice to meet you,
dude.
You're on naked and afraid Cheryl.
Cheryl was,
dude,
it's so,
it's so ridiculous.
Like to say ridiculous is such an understatement because he's,
because they oftentimes,
yeah,
we'll have like an actual survival expert or a wildlife expert or someone who
knows how to live in the woods.
Sure.
And is that was the idea with you get a wildlife expert?
Definitely.
I mean I'm,
I'm kind of a combo.
Like I,
I've practiced primitive survival for many years in a means to get closer to
wildlife.
Like I just got back from the Amazon and we had to feed ourselves everyday.
We had to build shelter,
Blah Blah.
And I don't do it like for fun,
I do it as a means to be out further and stay longer kind of thing.
But it's gotta be a little bit of a conscious effort,
right?
Like to have fun,
like fishing for your food shirt and you know,
putting up shelter,
I mean it's gotta be like kind of cool to live like that for a little bit.
It's a,
it's human nature.
You know,
like we,
we intrinsically want to hunt things and fish things and build a shelter and
survive.
And so it's totally fine.
I think it's like,
to your core,
it's fun,
you know what I mean?
You just feel it.
Like,
you know that you're doing something that's like primal human nature.
Yeah.
The Amazon fishing clips that you have on your Instagram page,
it's crazy.
Like you just throw a cast out there and you were catching a big fish,
like instantly bonkers.
Like I fished a lot of places.
I'm really into fishing and spear fishing and every Joe,
I'm not kidding,
every single cost was a fish,
a peacock bass or a pronto.
Every cost.
And where we were in the Amazon super remote,
like not a lot of people go there.
I'm sure those fish have never,
ever seen a lure.
Never seen a hook before.
And uh,
it wasn't like sport fishing.
It was like,
okay,
let's go catch 10 fish.
In other words take 10 cost and we have enough food and that was it.
And it was amazing.
Does it make you think of what the ocean must have been like before?
People fucked it up?
Of course.
I mean of course as a biologist that's like all I can think about,
cause I was in Hawaii recently and we did some snorkeling and when you're
swimming around with the goggles on,
looking down at the ocean,
one of the things that's kind of shocking is how few fish there are now.
Like do you think this should be like teeming with life?
You know,
you're over these reefs and you see like three or four fish,
I have fish or something like that.
It's so weird.
I mean there's,
there are these pockets left in the world that are completely untouched.
And it's like as soon as you get into one you can see it.
You're like,
this is what it used to be like everywhere.
And it's like humans haven't had an impact.
I don't,
you know,
I don't want to disparage anyone in Hawaii,
but I don't think there's anywhere in Hawaii like that cause it's all so
accessible and it's just,
you know,
I've,
I've been fortunate enough to see a couple of these pockets and they're just
booming with stuff and it's like this is what it could be.
Yeah.
I mean
I guess that's like what it must be to just be in the Amazon itself as well.
Right?
For sure.
The jungle,
not just the rivers and the lakes or whatever's out there,
but the actual jungle itself,
it's,
it incredible.
The jungle there.
So we were in Columbia and Amazon and like talk about untouched by people.
There's been this kind of ongoing going conflict in Columbia for many,
many years.
So we're,
we were the first Westerners to go there and over 60 years.
So the village we flew into,
they literally never seen white people before.
And then we went 200 kilometers from that.
So like middle of nowhere.
They want to touch you.
Yeah.
Hair because their hair was very dark and very different.
And like,
I'm not particularly fair,
but just to touch like the hair and see the blue eyes and stuff.
They were just loving,
friendly,
super friendly.
Like the culture was very stoic.
Like there wasn't a lot of smiling or crying,
you know,
there wasn't like a lot of emotional exchange,
but straight away they came and greeted us like shook hands,
you know,
said hello.
Um,
it was really cool.
Wow.
That's got to be,
no.
How do you set something like that up?
Do you have like a liaison that acts as a go between,
between you and the tribes?
Um,
yeah,
so we did in this case have one guy who communicated,
I speak Spanish,
Spanglish,
I guess,
and they all speak Spanish from back in the day.
So we set it all up.
It's part of the wildlife stuff that I do.
We,
we literally flew a DC three,
a World War II cargo plane into this cocaine dealers airstrip and then got,
that's how we got there.
I mean like mind blowing stuff,
cocaine dealer,
a former former former,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
TBD still Columbia.
Right,
exactly.
Um,
so yeah,
I was,
that one was really cool.
It really remote.
How crazy is that?
They learned Spanish from people who came over on boats from Spain and it just
stuck.
Isn't that nuts?
And took over the whole like regions.
Yeah,
the whole world.
And Sarah's,
this tribe in the middle of the Amazon that has this language from another
continent.
Well and Brazil,
right from Portugal.
Right.
It's really incredible when you stop and think about,
I mean we,
it's,
it's incredible,
but it's also part of,
it's a little sad.
Like wouldn't you have loved to have heard what their original language was?
Oh,
I was literally what it sounded like.
Well,
they did.
So it's funny because when they didn't want us to understand what they were
talking about,
they would switch to their native Indian language.
So they still had,
they were bilingual,
a community of 25 people that have never left and they're bilingual.
Wow.
It's amazing.
Now their native language is what,
what is it?
It's an Amazonian Indian dialect.
I,
I honestly don't even,
they might've said the name,
but I don't recall.
What is the name of their tribe also?
I'm not even sure they're,
they're so isolated.
They're unaware of what country they live in.
They don't even know that they were in Columbia.
Really?
They're just like,
to them they're Amazonian,
they're not Colombian.
Ecuadorian Brazilian there.
They're Amazonian,
whoa.
Yeah.
You know,
they just stay steady or they stay,
and the village we were in is literally,
I think it's all over 200 kilometers from the next,
next village of 15 or so people.
And they don't have fuel.
They don't have motors,
you know,
they just in this pocket and they just substance live and they're all barefoot,
right?
Yeah.
Do they have those crazy splayed out feet?
Big Feet,
you know,
cause they're there.
They're not very big people.
They're small Indian people,
but really big kind of useful feet and the way that,
you know,
they could run up and down trees and climb stuff.
And I mean,
it was unbelievable.
Like so much more athletic than you could imagine.
Imagine right there.
They've been doing that their whole life,
their whole lives.
When like when I say splayed out feet,
when I'm talking about as a people that walk barefoot in the jungle for long
periods of time with their whole life,
their toes spread out and their feet almost looked like a hand.
Oh no way.
I did not like pay enough attention.
That might've been the case,
but I didn't know that at their feet.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's kind of weird thing.
Stare at Dude's feet.
Yeah,
for sure.
But um,
yeah,
Steve Rinella,
who's a good friend of mine told me about that.
He was in Guyana and it's the same thing and they actually got some pictures and
videos of these people's feet,
but look at these guys.
Whoa.
Oh No,
I didn't notice anything like that.
Yeah.
This is the,
uh,
that's uh,
how do you say that?
Horror on not Horani Horani Horani sounds right.
Or Ani,
you think where Ronnie Horani Indian splayed feet.
So it's very strange.
Like it's the kind of the opposite of what happens to women when they jam their
feet into those little pointy shoes,
right.
Where they get the toes kind of smoosh onto each of that late fee.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
Instead of that,
they're all like crazy spread out.
What in the fuck is going on there?
The guys I talk with hands,
I think.
Yeah,
the tops hands but the bottom was like would feet,
but that's,
that's gotta be like what?
Our feet are supposed to be probably right,
right.
Yeah.
Thick ass toes that actually have muscles in them that move that you can use
like a tool like your hand.
Yeah.
So when these guys just can climb up trees with them so they grip the side of
the tree with their feet like a hand.
Oh,
I mean I didn't notice,
like I say the feet just like that specifically,
but the way they could,
like everything's covered in mud down there.
Right.
It's all wet.
It rains every day and they could run up and down these tree trunks,
like to get up and down the village.
And here's me and my crew with our awkward cameras and stuff and where it's
slipping and sliding and falling over and like they're,
they're literally like,
what's wrong with these people?
Why can't they walk?
We must have looked like infants to that.
Right.
And you guys probably have like boots on and shit fucked up.
Oh totally.
Yeah.
We're wearing,
you know,
muck boots and my one buddies got waiters on and you know,
we think we're all hard and cool because we got all this gear and they're just
like running around in shorts barefoot.
It is so fascinating when you see people that don't have contact with the
outside world.
Like,
um,
I'm sure you're aware of that recent story of the missionary was killed by the
people in north central island.
Absolutely.
Which is one of the weirdest places cause they've branched off from Africa at
60,000 years ago or something like that.
Right.
When,
when you're around these people,
like what,
what do they do if they get injured?
So
funny you asked that because we,
we kind of had that same question.
Right.
And they don't leave.
They stay in the village.
They have a shaman at the village who blessed us with a crazy green powder and
that's a whole nother story.
But they have a showman and he is their doctor.
However,
he has no access to any Western medicine.
So it's only his learning knowledge handed down through generations plus jungle
powders and whatnot.
And um,
and that's it.
So we actually,
we spent a day,
cause we had a medic with us doing like kind of village help if you will.
Everybody had ringworm,
everybody had respiratory infections.
Uh,
there were a lot of lady problems in the village that our medic had to deal
with.
I mean there was a lot of health issues and you don't even realize it.
Write something down before I forget.
I'm sorry I was totally unrelated but no good.
There's a doctor named Peter Hotez that's coming on the podcast now to follow up
on him.
He,
when you started talking about the people in the jungle,
he was,
he's a actual,
a doctor who is a,
he specializes in infectious diseases and jungle and tropical climates and he's
like,
everyone's infected with something.
Everyone,
everyone,
he'd have a heyday down there.
I'm sure it's probably been,
yeah.
But,
um,
the,
so when these people have ringworm and all these different infections,
do they treat it?
Do they have like some natural pathic tour or some shit?
I think it's kind of a 50,
50,
like a lot of it they don't treat because it's just part of everyday life.
Like when I say everybody had ringworm,
I meant everybody had it.
So I don't think there was any kind of treatment or cure.
It was just kind of part of it,
part of them.
But other things,
you know,
the,
the witch doctor or the Shaman was trying to treat.
Um,
and then we kind of went in and we had like medication for ringworm.
So we dewormed everybody and with the Shamans blessing and he was like super
excited to have western medicine in the village.
And what'd you use?
Like Lamisil or something like that?
I couldn't tell you.
Um,
I think it was not,
it wasn't topical.
I think it was like a Wehrmacht like a pill that you take that kills the,
kills the worms.
The weird thing about that is like,
don't you,
you leave and then they're going to get it again.
Right?
I mean there's only so much you can do,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
That we were having the same dilemma and it was like,
do we interfere because we're from the outside world?
Do we help?
And uh,
we talked to the Shaman through our translator and he said,
please help,
please help.
So we gave,
including him,
everybody just dewormer but you know,
they'll just come back.
Yeah.
And also they probably don't understand the consequences of taking some
antibiotic that's going to do some weird shit to your whole biome.
Right,
right,
right.
And these are all that stuff too.
It's such a moral dilemma.
You're there and you're like,
I want to help.
Do I,
is it helpful?
Is it hindering?
Our medic was like,
it's undeniably going to help,
you know,
they need this.
And so we got,
we went for it and it was,
you know,
it seemed to help.
Everybody felt fine,
but we were only there a couple more days before we left.
So who knows.
Wow.
When you're talking about ringworm,
like these guys covered in it,
you have big patches of it.
Like what's it like feet and legs had big patches of it.
Yeah.
And this,
if you don't know that's the same shit that's athlete's foot.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
I ringworm and athlete's foot of the same kind of funk.
Oh yeah.
That's why,
uh,
the People Tell You to pee on your
feet.
I thought that was just for fun cause we,
it depends on what you're entity,
but,
uh,
I think that's a,
the idea behind it is that you're,
um,
somehow or another you're killing the bad bacteria when you,
uh,
you're pissing on your feet,
you have athlete's foot that that might be horseshit maybe.
Yeah.
With me,
you always have to check.
Um,
yeah,
definitely give that a little looksie.
But,
um,
it's a real common thing which you Jitsu.
Gotcha.
So guys,
all the maths,
that's real common.
So it just,
it guys get it and there's people really fuck up or they like put bleach on it
and a bunch of different things to try to kill it and winds up getting worse and
also of fucks up all the natural skin flora,
jock,
itch,
athlete's foot,
ringworm or all types of fungal skin infections known collectively as Tinea,
Tinea,
tinea.
They're caused by fungi called Derma trow fights that live on the skin,
hair and nails and thrive in warm,
moist areas.
The jungle.
So it seems like they're just going to get it
it.
That's just what it sounds like,
you know?
But what did they do?
What do they do for it?
I didn't see them treating that at all and when we pointed it out they're like,
yeah,
we know about it.
You know,
they were more concerned with things that were like dire,
like there was an infant and maybe not even for maybe three years old and he was
hacking up a lung and he was asthmatic according to our medic.
So my,
our medic gave them like an asthma medication.
And he just said,
you know,
if he has an attack where you kind of breathe,
give him this and like you know,
to be super real with you.
When we walked away our medic was like,
I doubt he'll live to see adulthood.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
And You giving them inhalers,
did you give him,
I'm not sure to be honest.
What it was that he left with him.
And what about like injuries?
What if they break a leg or something like that?
What do they do?
I don't think anything.
Yeah.
Was any,
I mean you got to think these people are climate trees.
Yeah.
My constantly fall get bitten by stuff.
There's tons of venomous snakes out there.
It's wet,
it's muddy,
it's slippery.
They're building stuff out of very rudimentary tools.
I mean it's,
it's nuts.
They have to get injured.
It's so interesting that we have this understanding of medicine and doctors and
hospitals,
but that's probably pretty fucked
recent.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll tell you a story.
Joe.
I was in my Enmar earlier late last year and we're down there filming this thing
and this kid,
like 22 year old crab fisherman gets bitten by a crocodile.
Oh crop grabs him by the arm,
grabs him by the thigh death roles.
So it breaks the arm and like,
I don't know,
15 places,
compound fracture,
the real deal.
I could show you pictures out,
it'll blow your mind and we hear about this and we're minutes away.
We just,
it's kind of one of the similar situations where we're the first westerners to
be there in a long time.
We go bombing over at high speed and we get there and the mom is like off
mourning the death of her child but her child is sitting there still alive.
Like they have written him off and his mom,
his mom is literally mourning the death of her child and he's,
he's lying there conscious but like in total shock,
fortunately just because of the situation we had a speedboat,
everything else,
we bandaged him up.
You know,
ted tried to keep his arms stable and his leg stable,
put them in our speed boat and it was six hours by speedboat to a village that
had a or two to a hospital.
Really.
And so he got there and his life was saved.
But I asked,
we asked the people in the village,
what were you going to do?
And they're like,
there's nothing we can do.
Wow.
So he was just going to bleed out or go septic.
And that was the end of it.
Ooh.
What a fucking rough way to go.
Right.
How did he get away from the crocodile?
Uh,
I don't know.
I think he was just hitting it or hammering on it.
He was crab fishing in the water and it came up and grabbed him,
rolled a few times,
and at some point he escaped.
How we even got back in the boat and made it back to the village.
I have no idea because his leg was shattered,
his arm was shattered.
It was brutal.
And it was a canoe,
you know,
it wasn't like he had a little motor or a wheel to drive canoed back.
One of the most disturbing stories I ever read was,
um,
these guys were kayaking in an African river and the guy in front of them got
grabbed by a crocodile and that it went under and the like,
it like plunge like a bobber as the crocodile pulled him out of the bottom of
the Kayak.
I'm like,
fuck,
that's awful.
Imagine being the guy behind him
and Washington watching.
Yeah.
And knowing that you're pretty much helpless.
Did you see any jaguars or anything?
Uh,
I've never seen a Jaguar.
I've seen a lot of la.
I'm from Africa.
I don't know if you knew that,
but,
so I've seen a lot of lions growing up.
My family did safaris.
Um,
and then I've seen,
you know,
mountain lions here in California,
a leopard,
stuff like that.
I've never seen a wild Jaguar.
Really?
Yeah.
When you were in the Amazon,
I think they're really elusive.
I know there's areas that are our hot spots.
All of the locals were very nervous and kind of knew about them.
Like,
you know,
I went out for Bush walks at night and stuff and I'd just go,
me and one guy with a camera and a,
they were like,
oh,
be careful like pedagogues.
So in a very dangerous don't do it.
Um,
but prior Grosso means very dangerous.
Peligroso is danger.
Yeah.
And I'm so we just go and you know,
I'm not trying to act like we were tougher than them or anything.
We would love to have seen one,
but they were very aware of them.
So they were there.
We just didn't happen to run into one.
Sort of like
mountain lions.
Exactly like the,
they say that mountain lines are like,
if you live in a place that has them,
you know,
Wyoming or Colorado or something like that,
they know where you are.
Right,
right.
They might be around you all the time and you might rarely see them.
Exactly.
Be Driving home and see one skittering into the,
into the
bush.
There was a nuts video,
I think it was from the La area.
Did you ever see it?
Where the security cams picked up this mountain lion that was walking through
this like very residential neighborhood and you'd see like people would walk by
and then 30 seconds later he'd like tip out of the shadows and then dip back in
and then the next set of people would walk by and nobody had any clue he was
there.
Yeah.
It's crazy that it was a giant Predator can move around like that.
Right?
Yeah.
So when you're there,
like
what would you have done if someone got bit by a venomous snake or a spider or
something like that.
Did you guys have any antivenom?
Were you prepared for something like that?
I mean,
that's my department,
right?
Like as the wildlife that's,
that's kind of my,
my department is make sure nobody gets bitten,
make sure nothing like that happens.
And we handled very,
very many venomous snakes and caught anacondas and all kinds of great stuff.
We did have like my main camera,
Guy's name's Mitch,
he got absolutely lit up by these wasps one night and we all were,
we got like 1214 stinks each.
But I look back in the canoe at one point and his eyes are just super swollen.
He's bright red,
he's sweating.
I'm like Mitchie.
Okay.
He's like his throat started to close up.
He was having an allergic reaction so we had to hit them with anti histamines
and I,
I'm not actually sure if the medic administered the Epi pen or not,
but uh,
he was like,
we're in the middle of the jungle.
We're six hours from a village that's then a full day's travel by a charter
plane from a hospital.
I mean,
middle of fucking nowhere.
And uh,
and his throat's closing up and think that's why we take a medic with us.
Thankfully we had this emergency medic,
he administered the antihistamines and Mitch was okay,
but these things do happen
to whoever.
Like while you were on these crazy adventures,
do you ever out there going,
this is the last one?
No,
no,
no.
Ever.
No Way,
man.
I love it.
I live for it.
Wow.
How long have you been doing this?
I mean like for TV,
for Animal Planet,
uh,
three years I guess,
but to go and the reason I got into that and doing it for TV is because I've
been doing it like my whole life.
I grew up in Zimbabwe.
My mom was a bush pilot,
so when we weren't on Safari,
she was like flying us these remote place in the middle of the Bush and we were
going out on safari and like as long as I can remember,
this has been what I do
now.
When you go on Safari,
you and those open jeeps walking safaris.
Whoa.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
We take a four or five,
eight an elephant gun,
put it on your shoulder and it helps walking safari.
God Damn Man.
Only during the day,
right.
Obviously cannot move at night.
And what do you do when you're confronted?
Okay.
I mean,
I've had some pretty close calls.
My wife Jess,
he's here with me.
I saved her from a hippo.
Oh yeah.
We've had some pretty close calls
and one of my scariest pictures I ever saw was this guy,
this African guy running down the street.
And a hippo was chasing him.
And you look at the size of the hippo and you're like,
good Christ.
That thing is huge
there Joe.
They are the scariest animals on earth,
like interacting with a hippopotamus there.
So erratic.
They're so unpredictable.
If they feel threatened at all,
I mean,
yeah,
they're just,
this video is fucking bananas.
Oh yeah.
This is,
this guy's on a row,
a motorboat and the hippo is swimming after him like a torpedo.
So this is where I'm from.
This is Zimbabwe.
Really?
Yeah.
So it was this common that they swim that fast.
They can move.
I mean this is that this is uncommon to have one chase the boat and come that
close.
But a fuck
can big it is,
man.
Yeah.
So when you've had these close encounters,
what do you do?
You shoot at the air it shoot at the ground,
scare him away.
Fortunately I've,
I've never had to put an animal down,
but I know people that have,
does the picture look at it?
That's it.
That's the one.
What
in the fuck?
How fast is big bastard run?
Ah,
I don't know.
You'd have to look up the exact speed,
but definitely at top speed.
Definitely faster than human,
but they don't have the maneuverability.
You know,
you can kind of duck and dodge behind trees.
They're just don't run a straight line.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck that.
20 miles.
Miles 19 yeah.
Yeah.
What does a person run?
A Rhino runs 31 Jesus Christ.
She's a fucking Cheetah.
Can run 75 miles an hour.
Huh?
I thought it was like 50 ah fuck yeah.
Stephanie five a crocodile's almost as fast as the fucking hippo.
They're including miles an hour for a croc.
Fuck that be for sprinters around 2122 maybe sustain.
Yeah.
That's also a sprinter and rice and a sprinter.
Doughy white guy like us.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
So you just,
if you're chased by a hippo,
is there a move that you do?
Do you just have to go left and right?
Zigzag?
Yeah.
Maneuverability gets,
so like when we got chased,
we got behind a termite mound and then it kept going straight,
like hiding behind termites.
Nothing says safety,
like termites.
Oh my God,
dude,
that's so crazy.
Fuck man.
Is that this?
So that's the scariest thing in Africa in terms of like interacting with human
beings.
You know what the scariest thing in Africa is?
Mosquitoes.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
of course.
Right.
Like all old stuff,
you can see all the big wildlife,
you can kind of feel it out and you put yourself in the bad situations.
Mosquitoes,
there's nothing.
You know what I mean?
You just,
you can do about it.
Yeah.
My Buddy Justin wren,
he runs fight for the forgotten charity.
They build wells for the pygmies.
Okay.
And He's been bitten.
He's gotten malaria three times.
Yeah.
And one time he got it like he didn't even get bit again.
The malaria just returned lift.
So it must be in some way systemic,
I think.
I believe it is.
I don't,
I don't never had it.
Knock on wood,
my grandfather had it,
but I know that it's,
it,
it wrecks you for life.
Like it can come back,
you can get it again.
It stays with you.
I think that's his situation.
And he's a professional athlete.
He's actually a fighter for Bellatore.
He's one of the heavyweight contenders.
Damn.
Yeah.
As he said that it's affected his performance?
No,
I don't think it has.
I think a,
I think he's been okay with it.
You know,
he received treatment,
but it's definitely rectum on three separate occasions where he was,
you know,
basically on death's door.
Right,
right.
And one of them was,
and he flying back.
Damn.
You know,
and he's just sweating and it just rotting out and the inside was awful.
Say you want to ask what scares me?
That's it.
Yeah.
I'll take a hippo.
A snake,
a crock of Leopard.
Anything over that?
Yeah.
Malaria is terrifying.
You see,
malaria has killed more people than anything,
ever really.
Areas killed half the people that have ever died.
Oh my God,
that's insane.
Just make sure that's right.
There might be bullshit too.
It sounds good.
I think it's real.
I think,
I think we actually have googled this before.
The malaria is literally killed 50% of all the people that have ever died.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's not something that people were worried about.
So many different things.
And you should be worried about Miskito.
Exactly.
Well,
apparently they're,
they're trying to genetically engineer mosquitoes to,
uh,
to,
to be void of devoid of malaria
and they hybridize.
Right.
So my understanding is the way that it's done is they genetically engineer the
males to reproduce what the females,
which are the malaria carriers and then the offspring of that generation can no
longer carry malaria.
Yeah.
Okay.
Malaria killed half the people who've ever lived.
That is bonkers.
It's a myth.
Yeah.
It would have had to kill,
it says like five and a half million people on average per year every year for
all of human history.
And that's not a thing.
It kills half a million a year.
I think the real numbers,
like half of this said it would have to be five and a half a minute.
Okay.
So it's just one of those things that people say.
Yeah,
I like it when I should probably shut the fuck up.
But what else is new?
Um,
so how many people have they killed?
A lot.
Okay.
We'll go with a lot.
So there other diseases like typhoid and shit,
isn't there like a fucking case of typhoid in California now?
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
we've got some weird situations in this country with,
um,
you know,
measles,
returning and polio returning all these bullet came in.
Yeah.
What the Hell Nah outbreaks expands in La and Long Beach.
Jesus.
Cool.
Thanks for having me down here Joe.
Congratulations.
Decision.
It was my hand was sweating when they're different,
but it's different.
It's similar but different.
It's not typhoid.
It's typhus.
Oh really?
Borne disease that can be treated with antibiotics or something.
Yeah.
I'm terrified of Lyme disease too.
Have you had Lyme?
No,
but I have a gang of friends that have had it and it,
her Wrexham.
Will you spend a ton of time hiking around and stuff out here?
Yeah.
Well California doesn't have much Lyme,
but east coast it's horrific.
It's like everybody that spends time outdoors in the northeast seems to get.
Yeah.
And I don't know what you can do about that.
There was a vaccine that they were doing for a while,
but um,
one of my friends,
her dad actually got Lyme disease from the vaccine.
Like he didn't have it,
got vaccinated and wound up catching it from the vaccine.
And I think they were like,
okay,
fuck this proxy.
Sorry.
Cause they had it for a while.
I've done,
that's no fun.
Yeah.
So when you were a kid you were,
you were doing this,
like you've been involved.
So this is like the family business,
sort of.
My family business,
my mom's business actually was safari businesses.
So like,
like you say,
sit in a land rover,
CD,
animals kind of thing.
Um,
and they did a little bit of tourists walking safaris.
But then I grew up on a farm in the outskirts of Harare,
Zimbabwe.
And then whenever I wasn't in school,
I was on the farm run around barefoot,
catching snakes,
fishing,
Yada Yada.
And then when my mom wasn't booked up,
she had this little Bush plane that she used for safaris and we'd just adventure
all over Africa or Africa.
Wow.
So it was great childhood.
That sounds amazing,
but fucking terrifying.
I mean
it's like one of those things where it's what you're used to write.
I found moving to the states at age 14 and like trying to find my place in the
world,
being this weird little private school kid from Africa,
way more terrifying than going to meet a tribe in the middle of the bush.
Really?
For sure.
Why?
Um,
like I'll give you examples.
Like I always carry a pocket knife on me,
right?
My first day here in the states,
I go to school,
pull my pocket,
I'm sitting in my uniform because I went to a very proper English boarding
school,
pull out my pocket and I started cutting my apple.
15 minutes later I'm in handcuffs and I'm like,
what did I do?
What did I do?
I literally had no idea what I had done wrong.
It was because I had a knife at school.
Everybody I'd ever been to school with had a knife to cut their apple.
Like it was the standard thing.
So here I am with like police and you know,
guns and badges and they're throwing me in handcuffs and taking me out of the
school on day one in America.
And I'm like,
this is the scariest thing I've ever seen.
And I didn't even learn until later that day that it was because I had a pocket
knife.
And at no point did I think having a pocket knife was a bad thing.
So they didn't tell you?
No,
they just grabbed me.
There was like this whole thing,
like the knife went flying,
I was chained up and I was like,
what's going on?
What's going on?
And they're like,
you're in big trouble.
And it's like,
why?
And uh,
you know,
it was like little culture shock,
things like that.
That to me were like something I had done every day my whole life and now I'm
like getting thrown in Juvie for it kind of thing.
When you think back about that,
do you think that's just the consequences of being in a large population?
For sure.
Yeah.
I mean like we,
like I say,
I went to school every day with a knife.
There was no violence issues,
there was nothing like that.
But then you come here where you know the stabbings and stuff like that.
And it's because,
you know,
we had a tie.
I lived in a tiny country with a tiny population.
Do you think that it's possible that,
I mean,
I mean it's stupid,
but there's no way you could live like that over here.
I mean,
there's no way you could have kids with a bunch of knives.
No,
I don't think it would.
Just culture.
I don't think so at all.
I think that would be terrible.
And I get it now as an adult,
nobody talked to you about it before you left the house?
No,
my mom didn't know.
She's from Africa.
You know,
she's like,
here are your things.
Here's my cool.
Put it,
sharpen it before you got us to tell a man.
Wow.
So you were doing these always doing these walking safaris.
You,
you started out doing the driving ones and then eventually you started doing the
walking ones.
Uh,
my family business did walking as far as they didn't do hunting,
it was all photographic.
Um,
and we were in the Zambezi valley.
So as Mbz River's one of the biggest rivers in the world.
So we do these walking safaris and then we did canoes safaris as well,
which is why I have so many hipbone crock stories cause we'd be canoeing down
the Zambezi river.
Um,
and then taking photographs and seeing wildlife that way.
Wow.
What a crazy way to grow up man.
It was awesome.
Your relationship to wildlife,
it's just so different than the average person in this country for sure.
It's very intimate.
Like I,
I feel like I have like regardless of being a scientist by trade,
I feel like I have a very intimate understanding of animals cause I grew up
completely surrounded by them.
Now what other countries have you explored?
I'm over 60 countries now.
Yeah.
So a lot all for wildlife work,
whether it's for the show that I do or for biology contracts before I did the
show or just because like for instance,
when I got done with college,
I was like,
I had a little tiny little business starting college,
sold it and was like,
I'm going to travel the world and try and photograph these animals.
And I went to 28 countries looking for wildlife.
Did you have something to do with looking for the Tasmanian Tiger?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did know.
What do you think?
I think of all of the extinct animals that have gone extinct at the hand of man,
given the range,
I don't know if you know this,
but the Tasmanian Tiger at one point range from pop,
one in Guinea all the way down to Tasmania.
So not just the island of Tasmania,
but thousands,
tens of thousands of miles.
I think given the range,
the frequency of sightings,
the amount of untouched habitat in Australia and Tasmania and Papa New Guinea
where they just found a new dog species by the way.
They did.
Yeah,
the Highland dog and New Guinea,
uh,
maybe a year ago now.
Incredible looking animal like absolutely.
Could there be a very small remnant population of thylacine Tasmanian Tiger
hiding out in a isolated pocket of habitat?
I totally think it's possible.
And these sightings,
are they coming from credible sources?
So I did,
I did one expedition.
I've done two expeditions looking for title scene and one of them,
I was literally talking to the man who is the head park ranger for like the
entire north Queensland.
So He's a scientist by trade,
a biologist by degree.
And he says,
I saw four of them.
Whoa.
You know,
so this isn't like some crackpot drunk who's like,
yeah there they're here.
You know,
this is a guy who is like myself,
a scientist,
a biologist,
and spent his life in the bush.
He knows every animal in that area.
And he goes,
I saw four of them.
Wow.
So like how do you not like I get goosebumps talking about it.
Cause how do you not like take that as credible?
No,
that's about as credible to gets,
well look at that cool looking dog.
There it is.
What a freaky looking at the world's rarest and most ancient dog's been
rediscovered in the wild.
So this New Guinea Highland dog was thought to be extinct.
Is that the right?
That's right.
Yup.
Wow.
So this thylacine,
this area is where,
where they are.
Has there been a concerted effort to find these things?
Sort of.
I mean it's,
it's one of those things where like I would say the thylacine is like the icon
of animals coming back from extinction for Australia.
Right.
It's Kinda like everybody knows about it in Australia,
they're all care about it.
But where these efforts are is like outside of Sydney or you know what I mean?
It's,
it's close to home.
So there hasn't been a lot of expeditions really deep in to look for him and
that's what I did.
So there's so much belief that the animal is still out there,
that the uh,
oh shoot,
it's the university in cans.
I'm blanking on the name of it right now.
The university itself put money towards funding to find it.
So when you have a credible institution like a university going,
here's money,
go and find this thing.
You've got to think,
and I'm not a big conspiracy theorist,
but you've got to think,
they have some Intel that says,
look,
we're not wasting our money to look for something that's not there.
We've heard something,
we've seen something,
we caught something on a trail camera,
let's prove it.
And so actually teamed up with it caught something on a trail camera.
Hard to say.
But what they did do is fun this expedition.
So myself and the university who still ongoing with the research when it looked
in this area in north Queensland where I went and how far deep did you go in?
Uh,
1200 miles.
Took 14 hours driving and then hiking from there.
Whoa.
Yeah.
14 hours on dirt roads because this is the area where they've incited the most
numerous,
uh,
this is where that citing that I was talking about came from,
from the biologist as well as,
I think for other sightings.
The community up there is a place called Portland roads.
You,
you could look it up.
I think it's 12 people and wow.
Live totally not like the Amazon off the grid,
but off the grid,
you know,
it's all like solar energy and build it yourself.
There's no power lines,
blah,
blah.
So it's just this small group of kind of like people in the middle of nowhere
and almost everybody in that community has seen them.
So that's,
that's where we based it out of.
And then went deep from that,
almost everyone in the community and no one's took a photograph that they have
cameras,
everybody's,
you know,
everybody's got a cell phone kind of thing.
But it's like,
it's all,
it's always the same story where it's like,
yeah,
it was there.
It was late at night by the time I reached in my pocket,
it had gone off except for the biologist I was telling you about who said it?
Ran around with his dogs.
Yeah.
He's out camping and he's like,
oh,
there's this red eye shine.
And my dog goes nuts and runs over there.
And then there's four thylacine jumping around with my dog,
like for like 15 minutes.
And he's like,
I'm trying to get a picture.
And you know,
that's,
that's like 300 yards away.
It's in the dark and without the flashlight and the phone and like,
fuck.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's basically 100% of those things alive.
I mean,
as a scientist you can never put that in number,
but two pretty yes.
That's why I've done two expeditions and I plan on doing more.
I feel it's out there.
Like it's a gut feeling that it's there.
Did you ever see that?
Um,
there was a Willem defoe movie.
Yeah.
The hunter.
That's right.
And he goes and shoots the last one bastard.
It was a weird movie.
It wasn't weird movie.
It didn't really work.
Right.
Move.
It was off.
It was very strange.
And there was like a scientific reason you had to find it or kill it or I don't
know.
It was when someone was paying him,
wasn't it someone hire him to do it,
but wasn't there a,
like he was a bounty hunter for the animal because it had some weird genome or,
I don't remember.
It was weird.
Yeah.
So,
but that's how they died off.
Right.
People hunting them,
put a bounty on them.
That's how bad it was.
Yeah.
When settlers came to Tasmania,
which was the last stronghold forum.
Um,
they were,
they were killing sheep and sheep farmers things and the government was like,
get rid of him,
you know,
put a bounty on him.
What year was this?
Uh,
you'd have to cross check.
It's been a while since I've read,
read up on that.
But the last ones died off in like the early 19 hundreds.
Right.
They're all freaky looking animal.
There is one set of footage from it ever from the one in the Hobart Zoo.
And it's,
you look at it,
it's insane looking creatures.
Yeah,
just nuts.
You got that to play the video playing.
Oh,
some plan.
Um,
yeah.
It's a freaking animals.
It doesn't even look real.
It looks like,
oh,
like a cross between a tiger and a dog or something.
And it's,
and it's kangaroo by genetics.
It's a marsupial.
So it's got a pouch and it's just so weird.
Stripes.
And that's a strange
thing about Australia and that whole area.
It's like how did what,
what's this marsupial thing and why didn't that catch on anywhere else?
There it is.
Look at him.
Is that freaky thing and wait till you see the,
there's a shot where he kind of turns his face and does like a yawn and you'll
see he can open his jaw the way like a snake does to almost 180 degrees.
I mean it's,
it's bizarre.
Yeah.
To swallow.
Well,
coyotes are kind of like that too.
Not quite so extreme,
but right.
When you see a coyote yawning,
you're like,
what the fuck?
Look at that.
Oh,
that's so crazy.
Isn't that insane?
Yeah.
It's like a crocodile almost.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's strange animal man.
I'm,
I'm obsessed with them.
I'm totally fascinated by him.
Yeah.
I hope you get a photo of these fuckers.
Me Too.
And did they,
so I have in that area,
did you guys set up trail cams and we did 200 trail cameras.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then the university that we partnered with who didn't go as remote as we
did,
but they're still doing a big area.
I think they have ten thousand ten thousand trails.
Something crazy.
Like maybe it's a thousand.
It's a huge number.
So what do you do with those?
How does that work?
So you do like a grid pattern,
right?
So you know how trail camera works,
motions to activated,
blah,
blah.
So they just,
they literally,
here's the mountains,
here's whatever.
And they set out all these uh,
like undergrads and they're like,
place one every 300 meters pointing in this direction,
blah,
blah.
And they just do a grid and they do that for a month,
two months,
whatever it is,
collect them all and then move to the next grid and then move to the next grid
and just blanket the area.
And I think I could be wrong on this,
but I think the search that they're doing,
the university is going to be the most comprehensive trail camera survey ever
conducted.
And so as far as you know,
they don't have a photo of one yet as far as we know.
But think of it this way,
and again,
I'm not a big conspiracy guy,
but if you're,
if you're a university,
might be one.
It's like my,
that's probably as close as they have.
There's a lot of these could be.
There's a new one that just came out.
Oh,
see,
to me that's a Mangy Fox.
That's not a thylacine.
No,
look at the base of the tail is very thin.
It's caring and an upward curve instead of straight.
Like if you look at Kangaroo's tail,
it's very flat.
Um,
there's a lot of Fox problems in Australia where they're introduced could be
wrong.
Um,
you know,
as a scientist,
I try not to get too excited when I see something that I'm like,
this is it.
But it's hard to tell because of the way the grass is.
For sure.
He's got stripes on his back.
Tiger.
Wow.
A trail cam has captured an image that has excited Tasmanian Tiger hunters to
the possibility of the animal may roam freely across Australia.
Wow.
How big is that thing?
Uh,
they're like coyote sized.
We've very similar to a coyote and size.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
um,
don't you think though that if they had definitive footage that they would
release it to try to get more funding and dude,
the problem is footage isn't definitive anymore.
Like a two years last year,
I got a photo of a leopard in Zanzibar.
The first time in 25 years,
the animals declared extinct and we call it a video,
not even a photo,
a video of a Zanzibar and uh,
took it up the chain and they're like into,
unless we have genetic proof,
the animal remains extinct.
So I think,
you know,
so hard.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Come on.
Well,
um,
so yeah,
I think,
you know,
if the university had something,
they're trying to get enough data to really present a case as opposed to like,
you know,
throwing up a flag over something into one individual Fraser concern,
that's a bunch of amateur wildlife hunters would go there.
What does this chairman,
there it is.
That's my library is the leopard.
Yeah.
Wow.
Did you,
uh,
have you seen that photo or the footage rather of the Jaguar that they found in
Arizona?
Yeah.
That's really interesting to write.
Amazing.
They're starting to make their way up from Mexico.
It's such a weird region that because here's this huge Sonoran desert that you
think none of these tropical animals can make it across.
And for whatever reason,
southern Arizona gets Jaguars and Coda Monday and peccary and all these like
tropical animals.
What,
what the hell?
I don't know the answer.
What the Hell's going on?
That all these rain forest creatures are making it through this thousand mile
stretch of desert and into southern Arizona?
Probably Board.
It could be for cool,
cool places to visit.
You know,
maybe they,
I mean,
maybe it's just like a natural instinct to Rome and expand your territory.
There is,
yeah,
look at that thing.
Amazing.
That's an incredible animal.
So beautiful.
And it's huge.
Huge there.
There are 200 plus pounds,
right?
Big fucking aggressive.
Kat.
What's bigger?
A Jaguar or a leopard?
Leopard.
Yeah.
And that's even bigger,
but it's such a beautiful animal to,
and apparently they were all over North America,
Jaguar point in time.
Yeah.
Look at that area like Texas during the rezoning.
Oh,
interesting.
I didn't even know that.
But,
um,
when did they,
I mean,
they,
they were pushed out of,
I've,
I feel like that might not be true though.
I feel like there were,
they were more numerous in like Arizona and like the southwest makes sense.
I mean,
you know,
we had so much mega fauna here back in the day,
um,
there would have been a lot of pray for them now because of the fact that he
spent so much time in the wild and,
you know,
and that you have this interest in these,
uh,
what would you call cryptozoology animals?
I'm not a crypto guy,
so just to be clear and nothing against crypto guys,
but I don't do lock Nasser big foot or anything and I'm a true wildlife
biologist,
so I only focused on wildlife.
So not to interrupt you,
but I'm just very,
very structured in the sense that I really only look for animals that we,
we have an understanding of.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
yeah.
the big foot one is the most compelling,
but also probably the most bullshit.
I think there's a mix there.
I think people believe that they've seen certain things.
Um,
you know,
it's due.
I think that there could have been large primates that we attribute to big foot.
Sure.
Whether they're still here or not,
whether people have ever seen him.
I,
I'm so like not well read on that.
Isn't it interesting though that if there was one it would probably be the most
spectacular find ever.
Absolutely.
Love Nima.
We have chimps and Bonobos.
Right.
And you know,
we have all these things that are real well cause there's so much like Laura and
culture associated with it.
Right.
And not just like our western culture,
but like cave paintings of big hairy creatures and like everything.
I mean it would be like this mind blowing discovery.
Have you ever went and looked for the Bondo ape?
No.
I know what it is,
but no,
never gone and looked for it.
I'm sure that's a real thing.
Really.
Yeah.
They've got skulls and hair samples and photographs and video and for people
don't know what we're talking about.
It's a gigantic chimpanzee.
Right?
Like a six foot tall chimpanzee,
which is just fucking nuts.
And it does walk a rack,
right?
Sometimes.
Yeah.
There's a camera trap photo.
There's a guy named Doctor Carl.
Oh no,
he's not a doctor.
I think his name's Karl Harmon.
Karl Karl,
something harmonic Ahmad Ahmad Ahmad.
And he's a,
uh,
it was it Swiss wildlife photographer.
Anyway,
he set up a bunch of camera traps and he got one of the one walking.
It's freaking,
there's some photos of these gentlemen that shot one,
uh,
near an airstrip.
Huh.
And it's fucking huge.
You don't know how big the men are.
They might be small and it's in front of them,
but it is without a doubt,
one of the biggest chimpanzees you've ever seen in line.
They have a crest on their head.
Their skull has a crest.
Like a gorilla,
Huh.
Yeah.
And it was like the bone of the skull has kind of fuse.
Which have a picture of that.
I'd love to see it.
I'm not not familiar with the anatomy of them.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's really interesting because I think for the longest time they didn't think
they were real as a part of that Michael Crighton Book Congo,
because remember there was a really terrible movie.
I know that little,
the size of that fucker.
That's insane.
Yeah.
That's one of them.
And that thing that doesn't look like forced perspective,
you know what I mean?
It looks like they're right in front of them.
And that's one from the early 19 hundreds I believe.
Where these guys a shot one.
And um,
there were like,
what is this?
This is just giant chimp goat.
Did see if he could find the one of the red above is the one where it's walking
right there.
Yeah.
Oh that's the camera trap.
Wow.
Walking and he's erect.
Yeah,
he's erect.
And he's,
you know,
Izzy,
these people that,
one of,
one of the sightings,
they saw one walk by a truck,
like walk across the road,
they said it was the same height as the truck.
That's insane.
So they have like,
you know,
like a Toyota Helix or something like that.
And it's literally the size,
the height,
like a six foot tall man,
but a giant chimp.
And I mean,
you know,
to go back to the big foot thing,
you can totally see where we get that from.
Right.
You look at this huge primate that's the size of a human being and your brain
instantly goes,
it's mythological.
And I'm pretty sure that they didn't have photos of this thing until the 20th
century.
Like the late 20th century.
No kidding.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
It's a trip,
man.
This,
they nest on the ground.
Like I'm like gorilla the gorilla.
Yeah.
Wow.
And uh,
the locals have tune different names for,
uh,
two different names for chimps.
They call it a tree.
Beaders and lion killers and the tree beaters are the ones that are up in the
trees,
a smaller champs.
The lion killers are these big ones that live on the ground.
And apparently there's some either video footage or there was some eyewitness
account of one of them eating a leopard.
No.
So it was a dead leopard that they were eating.
Whether or not they killed it or they found it,
but they were eating this fucker
regardless like to be a primate at the top of the food chain,
eating a big cat.
I mean,
that's nuts.
It's nuts.
Would you ever think of going there and trying to find those things?
They're deep in their great,
yeah,
I think they're in a place called ble,
ble in the Congo.
That's where they think they are.
They've isolated a population of them there.
Really.
My mom just got back from the Congo and she still does like her own adventure
stuff and she was saying it's just like she's been all over as well.
She's like,
it's mind blowing.
Like there's so much remoteness and unstudied area that there could be all kinds
of things.
God Damn Man.
Now what,
what kind of medication do you have to take if you're going to go there?
Because you have to take some anti-malarial stuff,
right?
I'm a pin cushion.
Like I've had so many shots and pills and you know,
like the preventative,
obviously I actually don't do malaria medication.
I just cover up.
Um,
because it messes with your brain.
I don't know if you know that.
Like they say the new modern ones aren't bad,
but the malarone like you have hallucinations at night.
You have crazy sweats,
like,
especially if you're in hot sun.
So I,
I would rather be more focused,
especially if I'm working with reptiles or stuff like that,
that can animate me.
So I try,
I try to stay away from it and just cover up.
Wow.
Is there,
uh,
a specific type of clothing that's like anti mosquito repellent clothing or
anything?
Like
I just do long sleeves and some bug spray.
And do you do a mask as well?
No.
That's silliness.
Really look silly.
It does look sad.
No,
I just do,
you know,
good old deet.
God,
that's stuff's gotta be bad for you too though.
Now it melts you like if you get it on,
like say these things,
it will melt the painting,
the paint off of the headphones.
It's so strong.
It's probably worse than the now.
Have you ever used a thermostat?
What did they call the m fucking,
is it called Thermacell?
I think that's what's called.
Um,
it's um,
it's a device that heats up.
It's gotten like an element inside of it and like a little bit,
a little canister of gasoline and you put these sheets and it releases this very
fine mist kind of smell.
And mosquitoes.
Fucking hate it.
No Way.
Yeah,
we used it in Alberta.
Alberta has very aggressive mosquitoes when they're out,
when they're out,
they're out of them.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause only alive for like three months.
It's like Alaska.
You had been Alaskan,
right.
It's the worst.
Mosquitoes have ever seen.
Crazy going to pick you up.
Yeah.
Their size of pigeons and their funnel everywhere.
I went fishing with my friend Ari and we pulled up the car and we got out of the
car and we opened the car door and within seconds a swarm of mosquitoes was
inside the car.
It's
insane.
We were screaming like,
what the fuck?
This is crazy.
It's like something out of a Stephen King movie.
There's clouds and they,
I,
yeah,
that's why you asked me what I'm scared of it to that fucking clouds of
mosquitoes,
man.
Well,
we're very fortunate we don't have malaria here in the United States.
Yup.
Absolutely.
If it,
if it made its way over here somehow,
you know,
I,
um,
I wear this fabric.
You're talking about Thermacell called hex.
Hex.
Exactly.
And,
um,
I worked for a lot of reasons because I definitely feel helps me get closer to
wildlife,
but I've noticed mosquitoes do not like it.
So that's,
that's one of my number a heck suit is for,
for people that don't know what we're talking about.
So it's this interwoven carbon grid that actually holds the body's electrical
energy and capacity,
like the door of microwave oven,
like a faraday cage.
Right.
And so you,
you naturally admit electrical energy and then when you wear this clothing,
it's got this conductive carbon grid and when you touch the ground or something
at grounds it and releases all the energy.
So birds migrate or using.
Yeah.
There you go.
Now has it been proven that this stuff actually works?
I mean it has been proven that it has an effect on the electrical energy that
you released,
but has it been proven that the animals can actually recognize that electrical
energy with certain animals?
Yes.
So we know that electro reception is certain loud life's capable out of birds
use it to migrate.
Sea Turtles Use magnetic poles to migrate.
They just discovered,
I believe 2014 that lobsters antenna have electrical detective sensors.
Um,
I'd like to,
reception is the word.
Um,
so it's proven on some things,
not everything.
You know,
our understanding of animal behavior and animal adaptability is constantly
growing.
So it's passive.
You know what I mean?
I wear it because it's a passive technology.
It's like,
I,
I'm going to wear a shirt anyway.
Why not wear one that might or might not help?
So I feel it helps my friend John Dudley is a bow hunter.
Yup.
Pretty famous bow hunting.
I know John.
Yeah.
Okay.
And He,
and he swears by it.
Yeah.
He wears him constantly.
He's like,
it makes a big difference.
I think so,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm not hunting,
I'm just trying to get close to stuff and interact with it or find something,
but I feel it makes a difference.
Notice a difference personally,
especially with birds.
Um,
I've noticed a huge difference.
I've noticed a huge difference in the water.
Some mammals,
I've noticed a difference.
Um,
but yeah,
I like John.
I feel like it's,
it helps me get closer.
And,
you know,
keeps,
keeps the energy down.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you're admitting all this energy,
you see this bear or whatever it is,
your heart spikes,
your adrenaline goes and it,
it keeps hitting capacity.
So I think we sense that,
I think certain creatures sense that.
And I,
I like to keep that out of the equation,
right?
The,
I guess it would be that there is something coming off of your body and it
probably would be an advantage for animals to be able to recognize that just
because we can't quantify it,
right.
And put it on a scale and weigh out or something like that.
It's probably something going on Predator prey,
right?
Like if you're aligned and I'm an,
I'm an antelope and,
uh,
my adrenaline spikes and my heart's going and you know,
you're going to come for me.
But if that's out of the equation,
the energy stays reduced.
Well,
that's one of the weirder video.
Some of the weirder videos that I've seen,
I should say,
um,
is people that are interacting with predators,
like people that have like coyotes come right up to them while they're wearing
those things.
And,
and Turkeys as well.
Target it totally.
Like I said,
birds cause birds,
birds have that in their brain.
They have,
I'm going to quote it wrong,
but they have something that they can detect electrical signals of what helps
them migrate around the world.
So for sure I think it makes a difference.
Yeah.
So what else do you use?
You use the heck suit?
A ton of different tools,
man.
I mean I customize stuff,
you know,
like in the Amazon we were looking for Cayman and type of crocodiles.
So I built like a beefed up dog catcher that I used to try and last sue them.
I have a snake hook on me at all times.
Um,
Cook.
Yeah,
it's a snake hook.
Uh,
so it's just this like,
it's like a golf club with a hook on the end.
So I can work with venomous snakes without reaching back and grabbing me doesn't
restrain them.
It,
it actually like their body sits in it.
Um,
I do a lot of reptile stuff,
so I'm always have a snake hook on me.
I mean,
the list goes on.
Ton of trail cameras.
I use a lot of thermal imaging stuff like,
um,
especially like looking for wolves or something like that.
Uh,
we,
you know,
wolds are active at night.
It's really hard to get a shot of him,
put a thermal burden,
the air,
and you can see these,
these animals running through valleys.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's cool stuff.
You'd love it.
I'm fascinated by wolves.
Wolves to me are probably the most interesting animal in the wild.
Can't candidates man.
Wild dogs of all kind are unbelievable.
There's so at the top of their respective food chain.
Yeah.
We have a,
a lot of coyotes around here and basically they're a little wolves,
the little sneaky wolves,
but a real wolves like wolves in Yellowstone wolves and the northwest area of
the United States.
Those,
there,
they have got to be some of the most majestic animals there.
They operate together always these packs.
Yup.
You know?
So there's some sort of weird kind of communication and,
and what's amazing is like the social dynamic,
like within the pack,
you know,
the hierarchy and then on a hunt like you go left,
I go right.
But without any verbal communication and then coming together and making a kill,
I mean it's mindblowing stuff.
You know,
you talk about not understanding wildlife,
we don't understand how they do that.
Right,
right.
We don't understand what kind of communications going on.
Do you think there's some sort of like telepathic or is it just a facial and
recognition recognizing cues and patterns that they've established before of
they see an animal,
they know to flank it.
I definitely believe it's that.
Like I definitely believe there is an intrinsic understanding of you go left,
I go right.
You know,
facial recognition,
you know,
your,
your expression tells me to do something your dominant.
I'm,
I'm passive,
you know,
learning that way.
But I also think there's something more than that,
whether it's telepathic,
whether it's a low frequency sound that we're not audible to us.
I have no idea.
But I do think it's more than just visual cues.
That's where the,
apparently the myth of the Werewolf comes from is that wolves are so smart.
They think that wolf and a person,
we're like combined together.
I don't believe that per se,
but I can see how that came up.
You know what I mean?
It's totally,
there's so smart.
African wild dogs are the same.
Like they,
they hunting these huge packs,
they go over these massive areas and then they'll push a single animal into one
area to make the kill and they're not big animals there.
Again,
like our coyote size and they'll take down,
you know,
a kudu or some huge antelope.
I mean it's,
it's incredible.
Well,
African wild dogs are so cool.
Look to those black spots,
yellow and all the stunning,
they just,
they look angry.
They were like,
no,
there's,
I think they're,
they're my favorite of the Cam.
Like you love wolves.
I love African wild dogs.
I just think they're so beautiful and majestic and then
usual and they're just such a cool animal.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think all of them come from the United States.
I think all of them originally came from North America,
like I think on,
yeah,
all candidates came from North America.
I think that's Coyote America.
The gentleman who has been on the podcast before,
what is his name,
is escaping me right now.
Uh,
but he,
he wrote about it,
about,
you know,
all the various weather jackals,
Dan Flores,
he's hit,
that is a fascinating book.
Yeah,
I'm going to write it down.
I'd love to read it.
Great.
And I did a podcast with him,
uh,
years ago.
That's excellent too.
And he has all sorts of crazy insight as to native American,
North American animals that went somewhere else,
like a horses.
Like horses were native to North America,
but they weren't here when the European settlers came.
They had,
they went extinct,
but they had been taken.
They had the,
there were other places,
like apparently wild horses from Europe,
all originated from North America.
And we're taking over and then brought on another,
well from whatever.
And then when extinct here and then were reintroduced with the European
settlers.
Huh.
That's an interesting,
crazy.
It's fat.
And that's the thing,
like with what I do looking for extinct animals are proof that they're still out
there is like,
there are so many stories like that.
I didn't know that one in specific America is very well covered with eyeballs.
But what's to say there isn't some remnant small population somewhere in the
middle of nowhere that nobody has found these horses that have been untouched by
human beings for millennia.
Right.
And that's,
that's what I,
that's what I do.
That's what drives me.
Right.
Find this pocket,
find this animal that's been hiding out undetected for thousands of years.
Yeah.
So what other animals are you looking for?
A A lot.
Like we were talking about primates.
I'm going to Borneo to look for an animal called the millers,
grizzled lang gear.
It's a type of monkey.
Um,
I just got back,
I was looking for an extinct Cayman in the Amazon.
Think Cayman.
Yeah.
What's the difference between that and the Cayman's that you see?
A,
just a different species.
You know,
just like there's many types of crocodile,
there's nine types of Cayman,
you know,
you have salt,
water,
crocodiles,
now crocodiles,
same thing with Cayman.
Um,
and I was looking for one with a very weird morphological variants.
It looks very,
very different to any other,
um,
what's,
what's different about it?
It's got a very elongated snout.
Um,
if you've ever seen a gharial,
if you know what that is,
a type of crocodile with this long crazy knows.
It's like the alligator family that came and family version of that,
this really long,
skinny face,
super light,
super yellow coloration,
just very different.
Last time one was seen was 52 years ago and then they had one in a zoo that died
in the 80s,
and nobody's found one since.
Um,
so just really cool.
And so yeah,
the list goes on.
You know,
I,
last year I did leopards and I did wolves in Newfoundland and a bunch of really
interesting stuff.
So it's fun,
man.
You'd love it.
You should come with,
I'll talk to animal planner.
Scared.
I'm such a pussy.
Um,
what about uh,
giant Sloss?
What are your feelings on those?
So I've had probably three years of research into this,
into giant slots because a man man up put agree,
I believe is how it's said.
It's the South American name for giant slots.
There's,
I don't want to give away too much info before I get to do a chance,
a chance at looking for it.
But after all the research I've compiled there is,
in my opinion,
one location on earth.
It's in high Peru where nobody goes.
It's a bowl of mountains impenetrable.
The only way in is a helicopter in the center to me that that ball is going to
be like a primordial Eden.
All of the cultures surrounding it have old stories of giant slots.
They all have different names for it,
but they all have these stories of these giant slots,
right?
They were all hunted to extinction.
However they've handed down these traditions,
but nobody except for,
you know,
a tiny handful of like far out tribal people have ever really got into this
impenetrable ball.
And I think if they're anywhere,
they're in there.
Wow.
I saw a documentary once about this scientist that was essentially risking his
reputation,
trying to find a giant sloths somewhere maybe in the Amazon,
some somewhere.
Probably Peruvian.
Amazon.
That's where I'm thinking two and uh,
he,
he kept talking to people that had seen it and he never could get ahold of it,
but he had been there for years.
Isn't that crazy though?
Like why,
what if you're a little Amazonian villager?
You don't read,
you don't have TV.
There's no reason to make up scientific,
you know,
science fiction.
Why say you've seen it?
I like to fuck with white people.
Could be good.
They like get stringy hair.
Yeah,
I seen that.
Dinosaurs
and you're walking,
you're exhausted.
Covered with mosquito bites.
He's like any day now.
Yeah,
just over the next hill.
He's just going to wait for you to fucking rot out.
That'd be a mean man.
That's a mean guy.
And he's like,
you mean you want to log?
All right buddy.
Pat You on the back.
This is the last spot for you.
And I'll be taking,
I'll take your binoculars and,
yeah,
I mean,
there's no reason for them to lie,
but that doesn't,
that's like the thing that people say about everything.
Why would turn lie?
Well,
I don't know.
People lie for a bunch of weird reasons.
People do
it.
People are crazy.
They make shit up.
True.
Yeah.
I mean,
to me it's like you have to take an eyewitness report of an extinct creature or
a zoo crypto creature with a grain of salt,
but you still have to take it.
Do you know what I mean?
You still have to bank it and consider it.
Yeah.
And so that's,
that's kind of the way I go.
I,
I always talk to people,
but then I come up with,
I do the biology right.
I track,
I put the cameras out,
I bait,
I sent,
I do all of that stuff to try and get evidence of my own because just going with
eyewitness reports is,
like you say,
it's nothing.
Is there ever been any eyewitness reports that are just too,
too ridiculous where you're like,
oh,
for sure.
Like what?
Oh Man.
Loads.
I mean like talking about the thylacine for instance,
there was a guy that we met there who's like,
yeah,
their styles seen everywhere.
They run around with the black cats and were like,
what?
And he's like,
yeah,
there's black panthers too.
They like hang out together length.
There's an Australian exactly that.
I made the same face you did.
So I'm like,
okay,
tell me more.
And he's like,
yeah,
you know,
they like to hang out over there.
They're behind the trash heap.
They jump around with Black Panthers.
Oh,
they're just fucking with it.
And I'm like,
well,
that's the thing.
I'm like,
you're,
you're just,
you're either crazy or you're completely fucking with me.
And I'm not sure which one it is because your eyes are telling me crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
how many different pockets in the world are there?
Like that basin that you said you got to get helicoptered into?
There's a few.
Yeah,
you'd be surprised because you know,
we're here,
we're in a city,
we're so used to our modern conveniences,
but there are totally untouched pieces of the world's still.
Well,
uh,
do you know David Cho,
the artist?
I don't,
he,
um,
he went to the Congo,
I think it was the Congo to look for a dinosaur.
No,
it was a really early vice piece back when vice was first starting out.
And David is one of the more eccentric people that I know.
He's a multimillionaire.
He made a shitload of money gambling.
And also he made a shit load of money because he was at Facebook painted.
Yeah.
He painted Facebook.
What does that mean?
Like the wall?
Yeah.
The inside,
they hired him to paint,
like do these murals and they gave him stock and that stock wound up being worth
hundreds of millions of dollars.
And so now he's just this freaky,
super talented artists who is just doing weird shit.
And one of the things they did is like,
hey man,
you want to go look for a dinosaur?
He's like,
fuck yeah,
I'll go,
absolutely.
Why wouldn't you?
You know,
but there's this video of him,
I want to say he was like 25 at the time too.
I think he was pretty young.
Yeah.
Look at them there.
Oh yeah.
So he's in the jungle in search of a fucking dinosaur because,
and it was one of those things where the locals were saying,
Hey,
this is a,
there's a dinosaur in the Congo.
Right.
Which doesn't totally make sense,
but it,
but,
but who knows,
right.
Why not investigate it kind of thing.
Well,
I mean,
how big of an area would there have to be for there to be a species that we are
not aware of?
Like how big of an area?
Oh,
I mean,
you know,
that's,
it's a generic,
cause we discover
you'd have to look up the numbers,
but it's like 2000 new species a year.
But mostly little stuff.
There's an animal discovered most recently,
there's an animal called the [inaudible].
It's an animal that I'm actually working on later this year.
And it is a,
an antelope,
like they call it the Asian Unicorn because for generations people have been
talking about the Asian Unicorn.
And Western worlds like,
yeah,
whatever,
whatever.
And then finally somebody went down there into the Laotian mountains and,
and was like,
here's a skull and here's a skin.
And they're like,
Holy Shit,
this is a real thing.
And this is like in a Po,
not populated,
but there's plenty of people living there.
You know what I mean?
This isn't like,
this isn't like the middle of nowhere.
This is where there's villages and tribes and people and they're like,
here's this animal,
here's the skin,
here's a skull.
And since then I think one trail camera has the photo has ever surfaced.
Like nobody's ever successfully documented it because it's just this incredibly
elusive animal.
Like whether it has super sensory organs,
you know,
hearing sight,
smell,
whatever it is,
or it's just super low density and population.
I've,
nobody really knows.
But this animal,
this,
this huge,
like antelope has been around forever.
People,
little tribal people have been talking about it in like a mythological way.
The same way they would talk about dinosaurs in the Congo and the Western
world's going,
sure buddy,
whatever you say.
And then somebody finally goes down there.
Doesn't expedition just like David did and goes,
oh,
it turns out it's here.
Wow.
What is it about animals where we're so fascinated by the ones that might not be
real or that might be hidden?
Like what is it about them mean we we,
I mean people love to study.
Giraffes are things that are absolutely real sure,
but they also have an even more compelling need to search for things that are
not quite sure.
I'm not quite sure if they exist or not.
I don't know.
Man.
I think it's like
it's human nature to want to know more.
Right?
Like we of course,
like not everybody.
You see a draft,
you're like,
it's real.
I know it banked it.
Right.
Some people go to the extreme,
they study every aspect of it,
but as a general populous,
I feel like once we know something's there,
we want to know what the next thing is.
I mean we,
what do you think?
Like what?
Why?
Why is it that we're so fast?
Same with,
I don't know the answer.
I think it's probably a side effect of our compulsion for innovation.
Like human beings are constantly trying to find out new secrets are and find
out,
you know,
like find out new discoveries and invent new things and find,
explore new worlds.
I mean this is just something that's been a part of human nature forever.
This desire to improve and to go for the fund,
the next best spot for the new thing,
you know?
And then I think that also works with animals.
I think we have this desire to find animals that we didn't know or he or weren't
sure real well knowledge is the foundation of that,
right?
To go to a new planet,
we have to have the knowledge of how to get there,
to go to a new habitat.
We have to know what's there.
And I think maybe that's kind of that deep rooted desire is like we need know
about this
thing in order to,
to understand if we can innovate off of it.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
Um,
what did you think when they found that?
Flores man on in Indonesia?
It's amazing.
I like,
I'm not an anthropologist,
so you know,
that's not quite been 100% that is that 100% agreed upon.
I've only seen kind of headlines I,
I'd have to defer to you guys.
I think there was one,
there was some scientists that was disputing but,
but essentially they were talking about a three foot tall hobbit like man,
Yep.
Kind of cave dwelling.
Yeah,
yeah.
That little person,
Existed alongside human beings as recently as like 14,000 years ago.
Right,
right.
Which is like what I think it's completely believable.
I mean the Koi San People in the Sahara desert are tiny.
You know,
there,
there are big like four feet and until the,
you might have double check this,
but I believe until the 70s people used to go and hunt them.
Maybe it was earlier we just sixties or fifties but you could go and hunt this
primitive sized human being as like a PA,
you know,
as like a hunt,
like an old Englishman with his big mustache and his musket would go hunt these
people.
Whoa.
And now we have an understanding that,
you know,
there are people like you can't fucking go and hunt them.
But like what's to say?
There weren't tribes like that all over the world that other people used to hunt
that drove to extinction.
Jesus Christ.
Right.
What would say the name of it again?
So Jamie,
you got it.
You got Sun Koyczan?
Yeah.
Let me see what these people look like.
They're,
in my opinion,
they're beautiful.
Like you'll see what you think.
But they're,
they're very small.
They're desert dwellers.
You know,
there's not a lot of resources in the dry desert,
so you don't get huge.
So they're perfectly adapted to the desert life.
They really used to hunt them.
Yeah.
And they look just like people.
I mean you'll have,
but they're still around.
Like these aren't an extinct race.
There's still there.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
You ever seen the gods must be crazy.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's like those people,
those were kind of taller,
coy sand.
But those are Bushman.
Wow.
So who are these people that used to hunt these?
Like I say,
I kid you not.
It was like the old English explorer would go and conquer Africa and,
and hunt these people.
Like they were an animal,
you know,
fuck crazy.
Right.
And this was until the 1970s that might not be right.
That sounds too recent,
doesn't it?
God Damn,
that sounds horrific.
Yeah.
You might need to check that.
But it was not as long ago as you'd think.
You know what I mean?
It was like very recently,
they were still under under hunting.
Can they're people,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
So that,
that's probably what happened to a lot of the non homosapien human type people.
I would think so.
And even if it's not like for sport,
it's for competition or resources or you know what,
any reason,
and that's,
that's human nature.
Conquer.
Yeah.
Fuck man,
that is so dark.
Right.
They would go and hunt small people with a rifle.
Yup.
You know,
it's not there.
They're photos of people like posing with the dead ones.
Um,
again,
I'm not an anthropologist,
I'm not sure.
Yeah,
it's brutal.
Yeah.
So what are the pockets of the world are like mostly unexplored or could perhaps
contained some of these animals?
South America for sure.
Central Africa for sure.
There's some very remote parts of like Russian,
Arctic,
um,
Norwegian Arctic.
Um,
there's areas in Asia that are still unexplored,
believe it or not,
regardless of their populace,
there really are deep,
deep China.
There are some very unexplored area,
a northern Myenmar ecological hotspot.
Nobody goes there very impenetrable.
I read something about sort of some part of the world where they thought Tara
doctorals might still exist.
There's so many of those things.
I don't know that one specifically.
There's,
especially doing what I do,
I hear them all the time.
Right?
Oh,
you got to go look for a big foots.
Are It actos or whatever?
Mamet's it's,
it could there be a large reptile that perhaps flies?
Sure.
It's possible.
Is there a terror dactyl as we know it,
I highly,
highly doubt it,
but a large reptile that can fly it would be a fucking trip they were around.
Right.
So do you think it would be something that we don't know about?
Like,
yeah.
Basically,
I think there's enough pieces of this world that are unexplored that there are
still nega phonic to be discovered.
Not a lot.
Not a lot by any means.
And I might get ridiculed as I go back to my scientific community for saying
this,
but my belief is there are these isolated pockets where small populations of
Megafaun is still exist that we don't know about.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Well,
South America is,
I mean,
how much of South America is actually populated?
you look at the size of the Amazon jungle or something and it's,
it's the,
sure there's,
there's communities and stuff,
but not that much.
I mean it's there.
Australia,
you know,
if you're not on the coast,
there's nothing,
right?
There's all these huge chunks.
Papa New Guinea,
same thing.
Nobody goes up into the highlands there.
They just found a dog there as you saw.
I mean,
there's crazy stuff.
Now what do you think about these guys that are talking about bringing animals
back?
Um,
like as a scientist?
Sure.
De Extinction is,
it's a weird word.
It is.
It's where your introduction,
is that a better word?
They call it the extinction.
So with that's what they call it.
Yeah.
De Extinction is to me it's fascinating,
especially if it's something like say the passenger pigeon,
right?
We used to have billions of them and the United States wiped him out.
Um,
and now they're saying,
you know,
we can take the closest living relative,
uh,
isolate some jeans and make a new passenger pigeon.
Is that worth it?
Cause it's something we wiped out in the last hundred years.
Yes.
I feel like that's,
we should heal the ecosystem by putting that back.
Right.
That being said,
we still need to learn from our mistakes.
Like we need to take into account what we did and why we did it and like do I
think there should be a Jurassic park and a bunch of mammoths and TRX is
absolutely not.
That's a waste whether we can or cannot do it.
To me that's a waste of scientific resources that could go towards conserving
things that are on the brink.
Now when you say like he'll or men,
the environment or the ecosystem when you would bring back something like a
passenger pigeon isn't like 90% of everything that ever existed extinct.
Sure,
absolutely.
So does the ecosystem adjust and evolve and would reintroducing something like a
passenger pigeon would it kind of fucked things up that exists now where new
animals have taken a different position on the hierarchy?
It's too short and evolutionary time.
So we are in what's called the sixth mass extinction event,
right?
There's been five others before us.
The one we're in now,
it's happening at 80% greater rate than it's ever happened before.
So we are wiping out things more quickly than the world can adapt.
So you know,
you go into an environment and you take out all the apex predators,
the prey explodes,
the grass gets eaten down,
everything collapses.
Now if you left that environment over time,
over evolutionary time,
it would adapt,
right?
Maybe say,
say all of the predators got a disease and they died,
died out over 300 generations during that time,
something would evolve within the environment to adapt.
The prey so that it didn't wipe out the environment.
That's just kind of the nature,
it's balance.
But when you go in there and do it in 10 years or five years,
it throws off the equilibrium.
So when you,
in theory,
when you reintroduce something that's been,
and it's not theory,
it's,
it's science,
they've shown this even right here in the California Channel Islands,
when you put something back that's missing from the ecosystem,
it's like you're putting a piece of the puzzle back,
right?
And then you can allow it to do its thing over evolutionary time.
What did they do in the channel islands?
So I was actually a big part of that and I loved,
loved the project.
So the California channel islands were settled by agriculture.
There were sheeps,
goats,
pigs,
blah,
blah.
There was everything brought over there.
Right?
And so not Catalina,
but think about the northern channel islands.
Um,
what happened was when all these animals were brought in,
all the farmers were there.
Then Golden Eagle started coming over.
Golden Eagles came over to eat the pigs and everything else.
Oh,
flew across the ocean.
Yup.
Flew across the channel,
started praying on pigs and everything else.
There was an animal on the channel islands called the Channel Island Fox.
Very gorgeous,
cute,
cuddly little Fox.
Um,
you can see them if you go to Santa Cruz island,
there's loads of them now,
thanks to the work that scientists have done.
Anyway,
they were like,
okay,
the Fox is being there.
It is,
isn't it?
Gorgeous?
Little cute things.
So the Fox is being wiped out through habitat destruction through all these
undulates that had been brought in.
So scientists got together and said,
Angela,
it's like cows or,
yeah,
yeah.
Domestic animals,
cows,
sheep,
goats,
et cetera.
So scientists came in and said,
you know,
the habitats getting destroyed,
the and that.
That's just the keystone.
There were several species that were on the decline.
The cows are getting,
the livestock is wiping out the habitat.
The foxes are declining.
What do we do?
Well,
obvious answer.
Let's remove all the livestock.
So we removed all the livestock,
right through helicopters.
It was a lot of pigs that were causing damage,
all that kind of stuff.
We were moved at all.
Then the Golden Eagle started praying on the foxes because their main habitat
was gone.
So now the foxes are under even more pressure.
So then we moved the Golden Eagles.
This is a very abridged
version of what happened,
but now we've got the Golden Eagles also pushed out the Bald Eagle,
which are fish eaters,
which lived on the island.
So now after loads of years of removing golden eagles,
like relocating them,
removing all of the livestock,
now you have a healthy population of channel island foxes.
The Bald Eagles are back there eating fish.
The whole ecosystem is back in balance.
Had it been left the way it was,
what you would have found at the California Channel Islands over say 20 or 30
more years,
40 or 50 more years?
No foxes,
no,
no bald eagles,
a ton of Golden Eagles and a ton of pigs.
And likely over time pigs would have exploded to the point that they Easter
island to themselves,
right?
They ate up,
all the resources destroyed,
all the habitat.
Population collapsed.
Golden Eagles collapse.
Nothing left on the outlet.
Do you mean by Easter island themselves?
So you're familiar with Easter Island and South America.
I know what those statues are and all that stuff,
but I'm not familiar with what happened to Sean.
So that island is,
was an ancient civilization.
That was the Mech.
It had everything offline.
It had big trees,
tons of food,
blah,
blah.
People settled there and they said,
this place is incredible.
It's,
it's paradoxical.
Um,
and then they started cutting down the trees to fish.
They started eating all the mammals.
And what actually happened is because there were so remote,
the middle of the ocean,
nowhere near South America,
nowhere near anywhere else,
they cut down the last tree.
There were no more canoes,
there was no more food on the island.
And the population collapsed.
The island was barren.
It was void of trees,
void of life,
void of anything.
And they didn't have the canoes or anything to leave anymore because they cut
down the last tree to build,
build a boat,
or make firewood,
and everybody there died.
Oh Shit.
So that,
that's what happens when you use up every last resource.
God.
So,
wow,
when did this happen?
Uh,
I couldn't,
couldn't tell you cause I thought it was like a mystery to like what happened to
the population of Easter islands.
So they,
they're pretty,
that's yours.
That's the accepted,
that's the scientifically accepted understanding.
And did they get this from fossils?
They get this from bones and as that they've sort of pieced it together.
They took,
they take,
you know,
isotopes samples and measure carbon dating and Yadda Yadda.
I think that the heads are still a pretty big mystery why I think certain people
believe that the heads were like,
uh,
an Ale,
you know,
calling to the gods to help save things cause they were going so badly,
Yada Yada.
But I believe the heads are still a pretty big mystery.
But the actual anthropology,
the population,
the collapse is,
is known to be due to a running out of resources.
How long did it go for?
Couldn't tell you that they have an idea of how long the population lasted.
I think it's all,
I think it's all published.
Yeah.
I don't know off the top of my head,
but it was,
it was a thriving population that flew too close to the sun,
as they say,
because of Easter,
around small size and only 63 square miles,
it quickly became over populated.
It's resources.
We're rapidly depleted.
When Europeans arrived in Easter island between the late 17 hundreds in the
early 18 hundreds it was reported that the Moai were knocked down and the island
seem to,
did I say that right?
My why knocked down and the island seem to have been a recent war site.
Hmm.
Laughs.
Yeah.
Let's see.
The next one there.
Constant warfare between the tribes,
lack of surprise,
plies and resources,
disease,
invasive species and the opening of the island to foreign slave trade eventually
led to Easter island's collapsed by the 1860s wow.
So it didn't take long.
1700 to 1860s that was a wrap.
Wow.
It was annexed by Chile and so they've never tried to repopulate the island with
trees or anything else and they're just kind of leave it alone.
I believe so.
I know you can go there and visit it and see the heads.
And I think there are some things there now,
but it's,
it's barren.
There are no trees.
There's no,
you know,
it's all been depleted.
It's so crazy when they introduce animals to an island and it winds up fucking
everything up like Galapagos island,
you know,
and I'm sure you're familiar with the,
um,
Judas,
Judas goats,
Judas goats are,
those are the ones in the Galapagos.
Do you know how they do that?
I don't harass me.
Kate goats.
It's really interesting.
Not from the helicopters.
Yeah.
Well this is how they do it.
They cast goats,
like to hang out together.
Right.
But sometimes it's hard to locate them.
So they put a radio collar on one goat,
they castrate it and then they let it loose and they gunned down all the goats
around it and let that go.
Go find the rest of the goats.
He goes and finds the rest of it goes.
Then they gun down those goats because they have the radio collar.
Yeah.
So these,
what does this Jamie picture of a Judas Code?
I guess he's just whites go,
hey,
maybe there's a couple other pictures.
How sad is that?
Single goat's life.
He's like new friends.
What the fuck?
Helicopters.
So I'm actually heading there on a Monday.
It goes.
Yeah.
They make you take your shoes off,
right.
And scrubbed to make sure that you don't have weird seeds and the bottom where
your shoes
to stop eating seeds.
Quarantine for 48 hours when we arrived.
I'm eating.
Yeah.
So you don't shit it out.
Exactly.
Quarantine for 48 hours.
Yup.
Wow.
Why,
why is there so much concern about this one area?
Uh,
I mean it's the dawn of evolution.
You know,
it's where Darwin came up with a theory of evolution and due to the finches,
it's,
it has been destroyed in some aspects and it's been a,
the habitat has been fixed in a lot of places.
There's been great conservation efforts and personally I love what they're doing
because they're trying to keep it pristine.
You know,
I think it's fantastic that there's a quarantine.
I think it's great that I'm not supposed to eat seeds for two weeks before going
there.
Um,
and it's,
it's to keep it as perfect as it is now.
The island that I'm going to with,
with my small team has like nobody ever stepped foot on it.
It's an active volcano erupts every year.
It's this crazy harsh environment.
We have to have a new pair of boots every day cause it melts,
melts and treads your boots,
just walking on it.
It's been described as hell on earth.
So I'm stoked.
Wow.
And then what kind of protective gear do you have to wear other than your boots?
Just long sleeved clothing.
I mean,
is it yet,
it's,
so the guy was telling me it's like 45 degrees Celsius,
so that's,
it's well over a hundred.
Um,
and yeah,
and that's,
you know,
we've gotta be careful about water and hiking and there's just,
there's a lot of elements,
but that's the thing is I'm looking for an animal.
Nobody's seen and a very long amount time.
So you've got to go to these
places.
Nobody's going.
Wow,
that's incredible.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting the idea of invasive species too,
right?
Because like Hawaii's a good example,
Hawaii,
there's been talk of getting rid of pigs.
Yup.
And a lot of the natives are like,
well slow down because if they're what we hunt them,
we eat them.
And if they're invasive than what are we right.
Totally is the pigs were here right around the same time that people were there
and they've,
we've existed together.
They need each other and its culture.
You know at that point it's,
it's Polynesian culture to eat a fire roasted pig and hunt your pig.
And so it's a delicate balance.
Like Hawaii is a perfect example.
There's Mongie so were introduced that destroyed the birds.
And uh,
there's turtles,
there's frogs,
there's all kinds of things that have been brought in there,
but none of those are culturally significant.
Whereas the pig,
as you're saying is a huge cultural significance.
So where is the balance?
Well one of the best examples of that would be like Lanai.
Cause Lanai has this insane population have access to here and we,
we go and bow hunt them there every year.
They're delicious,
they're plentiful.
And it's one of the most really ethical hunts cause you have to hunt them right
there.
So overpopulated,
there's 20,000 of them on an island with 300 people.
Yep.
And have you ever been till the night?
I have,
yeah.
I was diving there.
A spear fishing there.
Do you see all the stacks?
Tears everywhere.
Every man is great and they're so beautiful.
Their spots and yeah,
they're amazing animals.
And you know,
I'm all for it.
Like hunting as a tool for conservation.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
But it's just bizarre that they did that.
They did decide to let dear loose and an island with nothing to eat the deer,
but people.
Right.
And then when this was done,
there's like King Kamehameha,
which is,
what year was that?
I couldn't say a long time ago.
Yeah,
long time ago.
So back then they,
I mean,
I don't even know if they had guns.
how were they hunting these things back then?
Bose and spears and they brought him over from Asia,
right?
Yup,
Yup.
They're from Asia.
Same thing with New Zealand,
right?
There's access steer,
there's goats,
there's all kinds of things are not access but red deer,
there's all kinds of things down there and same thing.
There are all brought in for sport.
Yeah,
New Zealand's a weird one,
right?
So it was Australia.
They brought a lot of stuff over there from,
from Europe.
But New Zealand specifically,
they were trying to make it like a hunter's paradise.
Right.
And I think it is right.
Tell me if I'm wrong.
No it is,
but it's,
it's a weird one because it's mostly high fence.
You're going to love this.
So under my extinct animal thing,
they've took moose into New Zealand.
They took like 10 of them.
Small population believe that they've been hunted out.
You know,
they shot the last wine,
blah blah blah blah.
There's one guy,
crazy looking dude,
long hair,
long beard,
like nuts looking guy.
And he's been on the hunt,
not hunt,
hunt,
but like trying to prove that the New Zealand Moose is still there.
He's found antler sheds,
he's found betting sites.
Some guy even got a picture of one standing on a rock and you know Moose to me
it's 100% and Moose and so they're in theory somewhere down in the South Island.
There's one or two or three of these super elusive Mousse that had been in New
Zealand for like 50 years.
Whoa.
Wow.
Well New Zealand
is so fucking rugged.
Yeah,
there's a,
a friend of mine has been there,
a my friend Anne Green tree,
he's been there,
he lives in Australia and he goes there to hunt tar and you know they live in
the on the steep steep craggy [inaudible] shale where the rock's real slippery
and it's just like cold.
That shit.
Really high altitude.
And you've seen them before,
right?
Yeah.
It looks like a science fiction animal.
They're as,
as me and my friend Mike,
me and the guys I work with like to say stranger than fiction.
You look at it and you're like,
that's not a real creature.
Like some kid drew that.
Yeah.
Like a big old shaggy weird looking thing where they think they are in New
Zealand.
The Mousse.
Yeah.
Did you see that picture of the one on the rock sticking out?
Yeah,
that's the last one that was taped.
Last picture taken.
1952 there's a recent one though.
There's one from like two or three years ago,
and I looked at it.
I'm like,
that's the most like,
I don't know who's saying it's not,
but it's a motion.
Wow.
Yeah.
From 1952 hmm.
That's 100% of Moose.
Right?
Again,
how weird is it that there's animals that you know are there and then there's
animals?
Like we must find that they spend incredible amounts of time and all these
resources.
Is that it?
That's all.
Yeah.
That's 100% of that's fricking moves.
No doubt about it.
So what I'm saying,
God,
people.
Yeah.
That doesn't even make sense that anybody would argue that.
Right?
That's a pretty clear picture.
But that's not proof because they need genetic material.
They need further,
they need something.
What do they think that is?
A cloud.
Exactly.
Oh,
rubber Moose.
That someone's stuck there in it too.
Goofy
people are,
they like arguing that somebody could have computer generated it to fool people
and all those,
all those.
And I appreciate it.
Right.
As a scientist,
I appreciate the fact that you have to have proof,
but it does get to the point of ridiculousness.
Yeah.
Well it's certainly possible.
It's certainly possible that they've,
I mean,
especially when you're looking at that insanely dense terrain.
Right?
Right.
But so there are some efforts right now to try to de extinct some animals there
are,
thank you.
New Word and a w like what is,
what is currently going on right now?
They're calling it the dawn of de extinction and it's,
um,
it's a lot of very,
very intelligent genetic scientists that are trying to isolate specific genes
that are specific to the animals that have been extinct and putting them into
extent animals,
animals that are still here to basically make this Frankenstein animal.
Cause it'll never be the animal that's gone.
Right.
It will look like it'll behave like it,
it'll think like it,
et cetera.
But it will never actually be the animal that we've lost.
At least not yet.
We haven't,
we don't have that technology right now.
What we can do is isolated genome,
put it into an existing animal that gives birth to an animal that looks and acts
very much like the extinct,
but it's some degree different because it's like part like of a mammoth.
For instance,
they would have to take some DNA
from a mammoth,
right?
That they would somehow or another get and introduce it to an embryo,
but how much of an elephant and the elephant would give birth to a very hairy,
very large task,
like these isolated genetic codes,
elephant.
And it would look like a mammoth.
It would act like a mammoth.
But the reality is it's a shaggy elephant with big tusks.
Right?
So if you did like 23 and me on it,
it would show what's mostly Elif.
Exactly.
It's a little bit of a mammoth.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you think of a double helix,
like a a DNA strand,
right?
You have these little bars in the middle of it.
So what they do is,
this is a very crude way to explain it,
but they pull out a bar from an elephant and they put in a bar from um,
a mammoth and then eventually you get this mammoth.
And so this would be like gene editing tools like crisper.
Exactly.
On those lines.
Wow.
And so how far away are they from doing this?
Uh,
it's,
I mean it's been successfully done a couple of times.
They've really,
they've given birth to a couple of animals that are very,
very close to the extinct animal.
Most of the time there's problems,
right?
There's,
it's in fertile,
it's a,
it has lung issues,
whatever it is.
There's a couple different cases.
I'm not a geneticist,
I'm a wildlife biologist,
so I don't really understand it,
but it's,
they've done it.
They have successfully reproduce things that are gone,
basically clone things and then the animal hasn't made it to adulthood.
And that seems really,
really like playing.
God does.
It is,
it is absolutely like playing God.
I feel like,
I mean is are people doing it just cause they can,
is it one of those things or zero,
like a real valid scientific reason for trying to reintroduce these animals are
extinct them?
Well,
the,
the valid reason is to conserve the ecosystem,
right?
Like we talked about,
but I think it goes back to what we were saying half an hour ago,
which is,
it's just that,
that quest for knowledge that can we do it,
the innovation,
right?
Can we play God,
can we fix it?
Can we take this thing that's gone and say no,
it's not like we have the tools to make it not gone.
Yeah.
There was,
um,
some article that I read where they were talking about reintroducing the mammoth
to Siberia and that there would be some ecological benefit to reintroducing the
mammoth because of the way they forage for foods.
Sure.
They would have some sort of an effect on global warming.
I mean,
do you know about that?
I don't know about that specifically.
You could find that Jamie,
the reintroducing the mammoth to Siberia to benefit the environment.
Look,
whether that's accurate or not until you put Mamet's on the ground,
how do we actually know it's a great theory and that's what science is,
right?
It's coming up with hypothesis and then trying to prove them and it sounds cool.
Like,
do I want to see a mammoth walking around Siberia?
Fuck yeah,
but does that mean it's actually good for the world?
Hard to say.
Whoa.
Could bringing back mammas help stop climate change?
Scientists say creating hybrids of extinct beasts could fix the Arctic Tundra
and stop greenhouse gas emissions.
I don't understand that.
I find it hard to believe,
to be honest.
Maybe it's just some scientists clever way of sneaking it in because he wants to
play God like,
Hey,
we're going to fix everything.
Yeah,
you fucking use coal.
Who gives a shit?
We got a hammock.
We got Matt.
Just give me the funding can be clean.
That's,
that's sadly very real.
Well,
is it really?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
look,
if you're a scientist,
right?
Right.
You,
Joe Rogan is a scientist.
How are you going to make your career?
Are you going to make your career by raising money through being like,
yeah,
sure.
Like I'll study cricket legs or you're going to be like,
look,
give me the money to stop global warming by bringing back fucking Mamis like,
right.
You know,
like why you can make the outrageous claim if you think it's going to fund your
research.
Right.
That's how you make your bones.
And that's,
that's one of the sad realities of some,
certainly not all science well mammoths to are so iconic.
It's such a freaky animal to study.
You know,
we had him here.
California Channel Islands.
Yeah.
Take me down.
It's,
yeah.
How long ago was that?
Uh,
want to say pre ice age?
Not Actually.
Sure,
but I mean still,
can you imagine like,
you know,
you're out fishing at Catalina and you look up and there's a pygmy mammoth on
the cliff.
There's a,
there's so many mammoth tusks in Alaska in particular.
there's a,
an Instagram page.
We can,
I'll just send it to you day Jamie.
Um,
there's a a page where they go and look for them and uh,
they,
they basically use like a high pressure hose and blow them out of a,
the side of a hill.
Is it like an ice or is it in like earth?
Uh,
it's an earth,
Huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
The bone yard,
Alaska is a,
the Instagram page.
If you go to the bone yard,
Alaska,
you'll see what I'm talking about.
It's fucking incredible.
I mean,
they keep pulling these,
they're using these hoses and cleaning off this dirt and they're pulling these
intact tusks.
That's insane.
But it must have been so many of them that died and they were pre,
I mean,
whether it's mudslides or whatever and they get preserved under these things.
There's this one pocket where they're all concentrated will there apparently
they find quite a bit of him.
That's not one of those in the uh,
in the studio.
Mammoth Tusk.
Yeah,
man.
I guess,
but it seems like he shouldn't have it seems like.
Yeah.
But you don't want it at some rich assholes house.
Totally.
What does that scar was?
Skull.
Oh,
short face.
Bear skull whole fuck man.
That's a cool animal.
Yeah.
We've uh,
we've drooled over those fucking things many times on the podcast.
See you right there.
You see those tusks?
Those are tons of laughter.
Yeah.
Bottom.
That right there.
Those are some tests that they pulled out.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
There's a ton of a man.
I mean these guys,
these guys are constantly doing this and,
and pulling these things out.
So let me ask you,
you're,
you're hiking through there,
right?
You're a,
you're on a hike or a hunt or whatever.
You stub your toe on one.
What do you do?
You dig it out and put it on your pack and you leave it.
Take a picture.
What do you do?
I don't know what the rules are.
Look,
if you're in certain places and you find an arrowhead,
you're supposed to leave it.
But rules aside,
like ethically,
what do you do?
Well,
it depends on how far away you are,
right?
Because that's a lot of weight.
So that,
that's,
that's fair.
That's fair.
I would say you market a market pin on a gps and come back cause it's like it's
something you want right as a human being.
It's a treasure.
Like you found this incredible thing,
but ethically you should probably shouldn't touch it.
You know,
what do you do?
Well these guys obviously know what they're doing.
Right.
For me I would s I mean if look at that one.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
It is huge.
Wrap it up with tape.
Is that what they did there to like it looks like all those,
those metal together sort of,
I like to keep it from falling apart maybe as they pull it out of the water or
the dirt rather.
Um,
if I was thinking of my best me,
the best meat would mark a pen and then alerts,
tell someone and tell them where it is and leave it the fuck alone.
Don't be greedy Dick.
So what happens in our lovers,
I dig that bitch out,
put it on my pack and not tell anybody and bring it back home.
I just don't know what the law is.
Sure.
And even beyond the law.
Like here's this gentleman right here is pulling this out.
Even if you don't know what the law is,
what's what's right.
That's the question.
Yeah,
what's right,
what's the right thing to do?
They might not be a good law yet,
but there might be,
I mean,
there clearly as a finite number of these things.
Of course there has to be,
and they're prehistoric.
Now,
let me,
let me pose this to you.
So I know a guy,
he's treasure hunter by trade.
Very cool old guy,
Australian guy,
lived in Perth and uh,
for years he's like,
I know where the certain Spanish ship went down.
Long story short,
he finds it right,
digs up one single gold coin and he's like,
it's here.
I know it's here.
It's big spear fishermen.
Adventure guy goes,
spends tens of thousands of dollars,
not a rich man,
spends tens of thousand dollars,
got gets all of this excavator equipment,
goes to this very remote area of Northwestern Australia,
pulls up something like $10 million worth of treasure,
takes it home legally,
declares it all.
Tells,
tells the government gets all compensated.
They give him three or four pieces,
you could see his treasure in the museum in Perth.
Here's this guy who would've retired,
been a wealthy man,
you know,
had his whole life taken care of because of this thing he was obsessed with,
and then found and then got the tools on his own dime to go and get it,
declares it,
and has a confiscated Tude.
Well that's weird because you find stuff in the ocean and they take it and
people become billionaires,
right?
They find Russian or a Roman chair ships filled with gold coins and,
but for whatever reason,
like this was considered like a history historically valuable.
So it was taken for the museum.
Right.
And he got,
yeah,
a few coins and no money.
I got to look up the guy's name.
I know a similar story.
It's happened in America.
Okay.
Uh,
the guy that went to hunt it got investors.
Right.
And when he got the gold,
he just kept it.
When the investors asked for the money,
he shorted said,
I don't know what you're talking about.
I lost it.
Or I don't know where I put it or I don't know where it is.
So He's,
I think he's currently in under contempt of court.
Oh Geez.
Being asked where is it?
And he said,
I don't know.
It's taking a lot of tests or tests that people think has kids have it or
something like that,
but they have no idea where it is.
It's a crazy story.
Well that's a weird one too because like what are you going to do with it?
Right?
Like if people are staring at you,
they're,
they're like constantly look,
where is it?
Where is it?
Like I don't have it.
They're going to keep looking like how much is it worth?
Millions.
I think each coin might be worth a million and he might have something like 20
to 30 of them.
It's like a lot of money.
It's insane.
Well,
you've got to bring it to someone who's going to give you a piece.
You know,
you got to bring it to someone,
but then then you're going to get caught.
Where'd you get the 5 million then?
What exactly found it?
Yeah.
What do you do?
Well,
it's interesting when things are historical,
right?
You don't know like who,
who does it belong to?
A museum.
Does it belong to the person who finds it?
Like what are the,
what are the rules and are we making these rules up as we go along?
It's,
yeah,
it's worth 20 million.
There's,
I'd found a story.
It's still in jail right now.
Wow.
Jail treasure hunter ordered to pay nearly 20 million.
This is Tommy Thompson.
Tommy Thompson's on it.
Yeah.
That sounds like the kind of guy.
What is that island?
There's One island that has,
I'm like this crazy hole in the ground that was made by pirates,
like captain cook or something like that.
Well,
there's a television show about it.
The Curse of Oak Island.
Yes.
The show.
Yeah.
It's up in Canada,
right?
In Canada.
Yes.
And they have some crazy hole in the ground right there.
Trying to figure out how to get into.
But there's all these weird little traps and,
Yep.
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
What do they think's in there?
Some astronomically valuable treasure.
Right.
And I believe the islands changed hands like seven or eight times because people
trying to find it have gone broke,
digging it up,
excavating and exploring it,
and there's booby traps and all this crazy stuff.
Yeah.
There's some sort of a method that they've devised where if you go deep enough,
it just fills up with water so you can never get to the actual treasure itself.
Right.
So the people mate who put the treasure there,
it might have fucked themselves.
Like totally.
We're assuming they're so smart that they buried the treasure in a way that
nobody could ever get it out,
but they might've just burned it in way that they couldn't even get it out.
I think that's the case.
I think it's one of those like,
oh,
we're going to keep it here and then they couldn't get it.
I mean,
who knows?
But yeah.
What a crazy story.
Yeah.
So do they know who did it?
I'm not sure.
See if he can find something on that Oak island so that television shows,
it's just like,
they're just like going,
well,
now what?
Right.
I think they're just digging and trying so he can't suck all the water out.
Cause he's getting water from the ocean sea level.
So yeah,
just constantly filling up.
Right.
So unless you go down there with the submarine,
I think they've put divers in it.
They've had metal detectors to,
I don't really know.
I,
I'm not super familiar with the show.
I just know someone that was there and um,
yeah,
I think it's this pretty serious ongoing thing.
Which buried treasure.
Right.
Remember when you were a kid,
there was x marks,
the spot,
the clamps.
Cool night.
The so called Knights Templar cross is one of the most exciting treasures found
there.
Really?
But they found it so called says upon first glance it resembles a knights
Templar cross.
Do they have a picture of that thing?
Doesn't show right here.
Mm hmm.
So yeah,
when they find these,
if they've in the open ocean,
when they find these things,
it's whoever finds it gets to keep it right.
If it's an international water,
I believe so.
So when they have like these ancient Roman ships,
but you still have to bring it back into port and to Claire it what makes it
historically valuable?
Like I think there's,
it's a lot.
I feel like there's a lot of loopholes where you can get screwed out of your
find.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
It's,
that's a weird one.
Who owns that?
Right?
Who knows?
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a,
it's just interesting to me that there were so many ships that went down that
you can find these things in the ocean still.
Yup.
Then they're filled with gold.
He's raise ships and people,
people retire off of it and you know,
spend their whole career and lose every dime they have.
Trying to find one.
Yeah.
And how do they coordinate?
Did they'd read like old logs or something like that and try to figure out which
way the people went.
And I had no idea,
man.
So what other like crazy trips do you want to do that you haven't done yet?
Oh,
there's a lot,
man.
I mean,
the one that I've had on my bucket list and sounds are,
so there's a couple of,
one is there's one really one place on earth left where there's true cannibals.
It's Papa New Guinea.
And um,
unlike the missionary that went in with an agenda,
I would just love to actually see these,
these cannibalistic tribe.
So I'd love to do that.
Nobody has successfully,
unless it happened very recently and I'm not aware of successfully done source
to see of the Congo River from guerrilla warfare,
from crazy waterfalls disease.
That's an expedition I'd like to try.
And then when it comes to wildlife,
I mean,
the list is infinite.
There's so many of these animals that I'm desperate to try and find those sound
like very dangerous trips,
like visiting cannibals.
Yeah.
I mean like,
I don't know how to say this without sounding arrogant,
but that's what sounds exciting to me.
You know,
is giving that shot,
that other taking that shot that other people aren't taking.
So have people visited these cannibals and come out of there?
Yep,
Yep.
There was a,
there was a nat geo photographer who got some incredible photos.
They're called the car away tribe.
And um,
he went in there,
took him a while for them to kind of assimilate and get comfortable.
And then he got these photos that are just mind blowing.
Now how often do they practice cannibalism?
It is a,
it's not a daily thing.
It is a spiritual thing where they actually eat the,
eat the other tribes deceased after a war or an inter tribal conflict as a way
to like ward off bad spirits.
So it's not like a daily thing.
It's not like they're going out hunting each other.
It's more like when these things occur,
they have to eat a certain killer,
a certain body to keep evil spirits at bay.
Do they get that version of mad cow's disease that cannibals get?
Was it Jakub Kraits Velde I know what you're talking about.
I'm not sure.
I think it's probably infrequent enough that they're not getting it.
Cause like in the,
in the South Pacific,
they got that all the time,
but they were eating each other like all the time.
Yeah.
Well,
I think you'd get it from nerves.
Right.
And nerve tissue or brain brain.
Yeah.
That's,
that's where they're getting it from.
It's essentially mad cow disease.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Is this guy hanging out with them there?
It starts off a sound and he's eating something,
I don't think cause eating people with them going to eat a fucking person.
I don't think they show that.
But yeah,
look at the tribe.
I mean they're just look amazing,
but it's just so incredible that there's still people that live the way they
lived many,
many,
many thousands of years ago.
And they essentially just get their resources from the land,
from the area they live and they're,
they're just rocking it old school.
And then for me,
it like,
the cultural significance is huge,
but what's the biological area like?
You're right,
nobody's going in there.
How much biological studies been done?
The answer is none.
And these people have large,
popular,
like,
look at that lady.
Amazing.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
do you,
have you read 'em Sapiens,
sapiens?
No,
I'm not a evolutionary book about even his Shola.
You've all Herati I think that's the name of his,
he's amazing writing it down.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a great book.
But one of the things that they talk about in the book was these nomadic tribes
that would,
yeah,
that's it.
Uh,
you've all Noah Herati I fucked up his name.
Um,
they would talk about these nomadic tribes that would kill the old ladies,
like killed the people that were burdens and like,
cause you sh shows like them and they'll just kill him.
Just talking about like with people became a problem,
right?
They would just kill him.
And this was normal,
but they got along together great.
Everybody was like laughing and smiling.
Everybody's really friendly.
But as soon as someone's seemed to be a problem,
they'd fucking club.
I'm from behind.
And just,
it's like,
this is gonna sound awful,
but doesn't that make sense?
It kind of does.
It sucks.
But it kind of does like you're a burden on the community or on the society,
you know,
there's no fucking old folks home out there.
Yeah.
That's,
it's crazy.
Like to us,
in our culture,
that's absurd.
But as a culture removed from the rest of the world.
Makes Sense.
Like you're a burden,
you know you've had a good life.
It's time to move on and there are no magic.
That's the other thing.
It's like they have to keep moving.
So if someone stops and like there's one guy,
he was sick and so they left him on a tree and he became covered with buzzard
shit cause the vultures would just sit over him and wait for him to die.
But he eventually recovered and he caught up with the rest of the tribe and for
the rest of the,
they call them something like buzzard shit or something like that.
That was their nickname for him.
Yeah.
Imagine being that guy.
Imagine sitting under a tree looking up at vultures being like,
it's moments till I die and they're going to drop down and eat me.
At least they're polite enough to wait for you to die.
They don't just,
the guy probably couldn't have fought them off.
That was,
yeah,
they're the trippiest of all the animals that the matriarchal society of them,
where the females have the fake Dick's.
They're amazing.
How bizarre.
So weird,
crazy faces.
Crazy biology and anatomy that fell a form that catlike but doesn't belong to
any family like super weird.
And a lot of them,
they have a giant fake Dick.
The females have a giant fake dick they give birth to,
they do birth out of rather.
Yep.
Yeah.
And they have an unbelievable biting power to write the strongest Mammalian job
pressure on earth.
What a weird looking animal too.
Don't like even with the weight will shoulder like totally looks like a villain.
Like it's upper body is like higher than its lower body.
Very strange dairy.
What is it like when you encounter those in a while?
They sketching very cowardly,
very um,
wary at all times.
Like,
uh,
I've encountered them a lot and as,
as it,
when you're in Africa,
if they're taller,
if you're taller than it generally won't attack you.
So people get like super scared of hyenas.
When I was a little boy,
I learned if you're running in the bush and you see a Hyena stand up and put
your arms up like that,
they say that about cats too,
right?
Like,
like mountain lions.
Look at that motherfucker.
Jesus,
look at that thing.
Man.
That's so cool.
It doesn't even a lie.
Go.
Huh?
Cool.
Hi Sir.
It's very cool.
It's not at my house.
It's so creepy looking.
Yeah.
I love when they,
uh,
they circled lions too,
like when they get enough of them together.
And let's start circling and snapping at the lions legs and strength in numbers.
Yup.
If you ever see there's a documentary on this one.
Um,
male lion who,
uh,
would kill all these hyenas and he was like the enforcer for the tribe.
No Way.
See how the hyenas would come in and fuck with the female lions and giant mail
would come out of nowhere and there's video of it,
video of him smashing these hyenas,
just grabbing them with his giant head,
shaking them,
snapping them,
a,
tossing them in the air and then chasing after another one and,
and killing them to unreal.
No,
I haven't seen that.
That's amazing.
Have you ever seen relentless enemies?
You ever seen that documentary on Netflix?
No.
It's um,
it might be on Netflix.
Dude,
I've got so much homework to do.
Enemies is a documentary about a very rare pack of lions that branched the,
the river changed its course and left them stranded on an island with water
buffalo.
Okay.
So they,
they developed like a much larger frame and they're like far larger than regular
lines,
like the female lions in this pack or as big as male lions anywhere.
Oh Wow.
They're enormous.
They don't even look real.
Is this relentless?
Yeah,
it's from 2006.
Oh,
it's not very old.
It's also book.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
but what's really cool is that they've evolved to take down these enormous
buffalo.
Sure.
So the,
the cats,
when you look at them,
they'd look like a lot that,
that looks normal there.
But it's all relative,
isn't it?
That looks like a normal one.
But some of them look so muscular,
they almost look fake.
Oof.
Oh,
he's getting is.
Oh Wow.
She's half,
she's getting the calf.
Yeah.
Cape Buffalo or terrifying too,
by the way.
Fuck yeah.
And she's like fucking,
but there's,
you know,
very few things that they can eat on this one island.
So they develop this ability to just have larger frames and they're much more
muscular.
And apparently there's that.
What's really interesting is there's this pack that's really big,
but then there's another pack that lives on the island as normal sized.
Huh?
Yeah.
So they must be eating the smaller prey species.
I don't know man.
I'm too stupid.
But it's the same thing.
So size of that fucker.
Leave that musculature and the hindquarters.
Yeah.
I mean she's built like a male.
She's built like a large male line.
I mean that is on steroids.
Yeah.
That's a big female.
They're the same thing that happened in Newfoundland,
Canada with the walls.
You love wolves.
So there was the silent Newfoundland and um,
there's wolves,
gray wolves for isolated there for long,
long time and day.
All Day we're eating,
we're moose and Caribou.
So they just got huge.
And they were bright white because it was a snow covered island,
like 80% of the year.
And there were just these massive white wolves all jacked,
all shredded chasing around Moose and Caribou.
Wow.
It's just the way nature allows animals to adapt to their environment.
It's just unbelievably interesting.
It's,
it's what I live for,
honestly.
It's so fascinating.
The,
the eco,
the ecological niches that each animal like fulfills and the roles that they
play within each other,
it's all perfectly balanced and to to see it and understand it,
like it's fantastic to see the individual,
but to understand the big picture of the environment and the roles that are
filled.
As you say,
it's like it's mindblowing.
Yeah.
There's a documentary on the Congo from the BBC from,
I want to say like the early two thousands,
maybe even late nineties and it goes into that into detail about how all of
these animals have adapted and like Dikers hikers in the Congo that swim
underwater for as much as a hundred yards,
no ate fish.
Some of them eat fish,
a fish eating antelope,
the antelope that swims.
Yeah.
And then all these animals that got trapped as the,
the,
this area,
these grasslands turned into rain forest.
These animals that were essentially like grasslands,
animals like antelopes and stuff are stuck right in the fucking jungle.
The swampy jungle and he see like these in these big packs of like antelope
running through this swampy jungle area where they just don't look like they
belonged there.
It doesn't say long and fields and that's how speciation occurs.
Right?
So that Dika over a millennia develops fangs to catch those fish and a crocodile
like face and web hooves or you know,
I don't know.
I'm making shit up.
But the point is that's how you get these crazy new species and here in the
middle of Congo,
in this tiny little pocket is this animal that nobody's ever seen before kind of
thing.
And that like,
to me that's what it's all about.
Go to the Congo,
find that thing,
you know,
is it there?
What is it?
That's why someone like me is so incredibly thankful that there's someone like
you out there because I don't want to go there.
I don't want to go there,
but I want to look at your Instagram page.
I guarantee you'd love it.
I'm sure a hundred percent sure.
I'm 100% sure you're right.
I'm also 100% sure I'm not going,
but I'm happy that you go.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm so fascinated by animals and just animal life and adaptation.
I think that's one of the more interesting things about this planet definitely
is these weird organisms that are trying to figure out their way to,
to survival,
you know,
and then we're going to swap the thing and moving and changing and we're always
finding new ones.
Like I found a fucking snake.
I posted it up on um,
on Twitter like a week or so ago.
A snake that has a tail that looks like a fake spider.
Have you seen that?
I,
I'm not sure.
What do you know the species of it?
I know the species.
Yeah,
I think it's from,
I think it's from Iran and its a rattlesnake hyper scale scaled pit viper.
Is that it?
Yeah.
So Viper not allow snake born Viper Viper.
If you seen that thing.
I know what they are.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
Looks like a spider and it tricks birds into coming down and try to snatch the
spider.
Here we go.
The Iranians spider,
that viper spider tailed viper,
like look at its tail.
That is crazy.
I mean I'm looking at that in a video and it looks like a bug,
right?
And so this thing moves its tail and it perfectly blends into the rock around
it.
Like look at that and I'm in that amount of camouflage and adaptation.
Like how does that happen?
It's incredible.
This,
it's boom,
oh,
got you.
Bitch done.
Zoho and the bird's like,
what was that?
That almost got me.
Yeah,
that's insane.
What an adaptation.
I mean like you see the Angler fish,
that's a very bizarre adaptation as well.
Same thing just out of the head.
Yeah,
I,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
I mean the fact that creatures can create that without,
you know,
it's not like they're doing it knowingly.
Cause some,
some handful of snakes at one time started wagging their tail and realizing the
birds came in and then over generational time,
this tail evolved little spikes and little things and all of a sudden you have
this whole population of animals that looked like that.
What is it?
How the fuck does that happen?
I mean,
how does something grow?
Something like that allure grows a lure off of its head and be like,
hey look,
it's something for you.
Eat.
Look at that one.
Oh my God,
that's got a worm.
That'd be the thing.
Literally has like a fishing worm,
like a bass worm.
I mean it's,
it's so amazing.
All of this adaptation and all of these look at that fucking monster with a
light growing.
I mean it's got a flashlight on its head,
but it just,
it's so amazing how much adaptation there is and how all these things sort of
work together.
Right?
Like there's the bacteria and the fun guy and the life and the animal life and
the predators and the prey and it all sort of works together.
And when something doesn't work,
it just sort of drops off and then the system sort of resets itself in a new
order.
I mean,
to me there is,
you saying it's one of the most fascinating things to me.
There is nothing more fascinating.
Like I'm,
you know,
I'm obsessed with it.
I live for it because I find it's so interesting
now when you study these things and you do,
do you ever try to think like how the fuck that happened?
Like if you see that that spider tailed snake,
is there anyone that has like an idea like that this was,
you know,
this was just a lucky break that this one snake had a freaky tail and then he
got the fuck a lot
does.
He ate a lot of birds.
That's the idea,
man.
You just,
I swear to God,
you just summed it up like that is the idea.
W one or two or three snakes kind of got this adaptation,
just a random random genetic sequencing that led to maybe a white watch on the
tail.
Something unique.
Doesn't it not seem like that though?
It seems like they fashioned it,
but over time over it they did,
but over millennia,
right over thousands or tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands of years.
The one what happened was say there's two snakes with a white spot on their
tail.
Then they have a baby and it has little bit of deformation.
Write a little thing sticking out,
then that snake all of a sudden catches more birds than the rest of the snakes.
That snake now reproduces offspring and its offspring that has a little bit
bigger of a spike,
catches more birds and so those become the prized animals to reproduce with,
to continue the gene pool.
And so that's what happens.
It keeps evolving.
It's like a peacock,
right?
But this crazy big tail that it's attracting mates with,
it's not useful to the bird,
you know,
that's entirely made for showmanship for peacocking if you will.
And it over generational time.
It gets bigger and crazier and more elaborate,
more colorful,
and the females literally flock to them and that's the animal that continues on.
What I really wish there was a way,
and maybe there will be sometime in the future where they're going to be able to
show you with like some sort of a super computer sequencing.
Would they be able to look at the DNA of this thing and say,
oh,
this is the exact progression,
right?
This is what it started off with and this is what it became.
Right?
This is how some sketchy looking forest chicken became a peacock.
Totally.
You know,
this is how some freaky snake became perfectly adapted to its environment.
I mean,
that thing looks exactly like the rock that it sits on.
Perfect.
Yeah.
So it is incredible.
Like I would,
I'm like you,
I'd love to know who patient zero is.
You know who's the,
who's the
first one?
Yeah.
Because stupid people like may look at that and they go,
okay,
well that's got to be a plan.
That's kind of a higher power.
This is something that like,
is looking after these things and making them,
making them evolve this way.
Right,
right.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's super interesting.
What about like cephalopods like octopus and cuttlefish and the way they adapt
their environment.
That's even freaky,
right?
Because they do it instantaneously.
And have you ever heard the theory that octopus or from
of space?
Yeah,
we talked about that with Brian Cox the other day.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not super well read on it,
but like,
it looks like a damn alien.
Yeah.
He was very incredulous.
Uh,
but you know,
he's obviously smarter than both of us.
Right?
So,
so he gets to be,
it's like,
yeah,
it's like me looking at tackling mad.
Does it make sense?
Of course it doesn't make sense.
I'm stupid.
Right.
But he's,
he's,
you know,
when we're looking at this,
but this is apparently like peer reviewed published paper about the possibility
of octopus being reintroduced.
And I think it has something to do with the way RNA and DNA is right on them.
Right?
I know.
I don't understand it well,
but yes,
it's like the thought that the population came from out of space because the DNA
sequencing and suggest something that makes it extra terrestrial adaptability.
Yeah.
He was super skeptical because he was saying that they're essentially so close
to everything else here.
Right.
That doesn't make sense.
But the other theory was it might be just this is the path of life.
And the reason why it's so close to us is that this is the way all life,
even if it's extra terrestrial,
sure gets established.
It's just,
I don't believe octopus are from out of space,
but I love the theory.
I love the idea of it.
It looks like it's from out of space.
You know,
it's just wacky.
Well,
it's such a cool thought.
Yeah.
You know that these things came from out of space as well.
That's also a thought about silicide mushrooms from the weirder people that they
came,
uh,
on asteroids and their spores.
I've heard that.
And they've,
I don't know if you know this,
but they've proven that certain,
I don't know about psilocybins,
but certain mushroom spores are impenetrable to the vacuum of space.
Yeah.
They can survive.
That's bananas.
I pick a lot of mushrooms,
not psilocybins,
but I'm a lot of porcine,
a lot of Shan't,
trails.
Like I,
I do a lot of foraging.
It's really fun.
Are you aware of Paul Stamets?
No.
I don't know.
He's amazing man.
One of my favorite podcast ever.
He's a mycologist of fucking trip in every sense of the word as super genius.
Mycologist who's the craziest story about being in highschool and what'd he say?
Took 20 grams of mushrooms and climbed a tree.
Lightning storm.
Which something fucking something where you hear him tell the story in your
hands,
start sweating,
you'll take away grams or 10 grams or 20 grand,
like something fucking bananas.
Like something that would kill Moose.
Yeah.
Well they wouldn't kill it,
but it would definitely make it think it's on a moose anymore and it essentially
changes life stopped him from stuttering,
he used to stutter and he did this and he stops done away.
I've heard about guys that micro dose with mushrooms with psilocybins and it
heightens their focus and curious or autism and you know,
there's,
I'm not very well read on that,
but there's a whole idea that micro dosing with these chemicals that are
naturally produced can actually have very positive effects.
Yeah.
There's quite a few people do that.
It's really common.
Yeah.
I've talked to a lot of people that do that really goes with that.
And they also microdose with LSD.
It was a lot of that.
Really not.
Yeah.
A lot of silicon valley people are microdosing with LSD.
And it's funny because the one person that I know that's done to microdosing
with mushrooms from Silicon Valley,
yeah.
People grind them up into pill form and in a lot of fighters are doing that now.
Really,
really strange.
Yeah.
So what would that,
why would that help you?
Like as a fighter?
Is it,
it's not a mental focus thing.
It's a,
it's a physical thing at that point,
right?
It's gets you into the flow state interest.
And so like with fighters,
the real thing is,
um,
it's not just your skill,
but it's your ability to execute that skill under pressure,
right?
So there's an overwhelming amount of anxiety.
There's extreme consequences to getting hit or going wrong.
Getting knocked out.
The losing a fight is absolutely devastating.
It's devastating emotionally.
It's devastating physically.
It's devastating.
Psychologically.
It changes your perception of who you are and how you fit into the world.
And um,
that sometimes,
and not,
I shouldn't say sometimes oftentimes impedes performance,
kind of come back from it kind of thing.
It's not just that the,
the consequences of it possibly go wrong,
make you hesitate and it just,
it's,
it's the stress of it all is very constricting.
It's very difficult to operate under that stress.
Sure.
The mushrooms for some people alleviate that stress and puts you in this
elevated state where they say,
and I haven't,
I've never fought on mushrooms,
but they say that when you're on mushrooms you actually can see what a guy is
going to do before he does it.
Interest.
You have a sense of what they're going to do.
That's a much more heightened sense than you would if you were just in a normal
sober state.
So are you picking,
do you think you're picking that up through like biological cues?
Like you could see the muscles twitching in the arm before the punch comes or
like what,
how do you think that?
It's a good question.
I haven't done it.
I don't know.
You know,
I've never sparred on mushrooms or doesn't like a good idea.
That's a really common,
they say it is a good idea that the guys who do it love it.
If an interest and guys of like,
you know,
had some really extreme positive results.
Huh?
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
I never thought as an athletic performer that athletic enhancement,
that would be a thing.
Yeah.
It's not just the,
I mean I don't think it makes you move faster or hit stronger,
hit harder.
But I think what it does is it puts you in the zone.
Interesting.
There's,
there's states that you get into where you just,
you can't do no wrong and they're usually very elusive.
They come and they go,
you know,
you get them like,
um,
do you ever play pool?
I did a little bit.
I mean,
but you know how sometimes you play pool for a few hours and then you just feel
you can't miss.
You just have this feeling of where everything's going to go.
That's even if you're not very good.
Sometimes those,
those little conflict to tree shots,
the zone,
you know,
and um,
that elusive state of like re,
and then sometimes you're like,
wow,
I can't believe I'm in the zone.
And then it goes away.
Right.
You know,
maintaining that flow state.
What do you think?
It takes emotions out of it.
Like is that,
is that why you're in that state?
Like if you're not emotionally attached to it,
that shot or that punch,
maybe you can execute it better.
It's possible.
I mean there's a lot of speculation of what's going on,
what's causing this elevated state of consciousness.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'll just start microdosing I'm mushrooms and going out to chase snakes around.
Maybe,
maybe you would be like more
in tune with the environment or maybe I'd get bitten and die.
That's true too.
Hello?
Is it a snake?
Fuck you.
You are.
Okay,
so I'm not,
I'm not like a big drug guy by any means,
but I think you'll love this story on this Amazon trip I told you about.
We land on this airstrip and then his plan we meet,
we get into this village and I'm like,
cool,
boats have made it here.
It took the boats five days.
We're going to head up river.
Right?
And are like translators,
like you can't do that yet.
I'm like,
what do you mean?
Like we've spent months planning this.
He's like,
you have to have the Shamans blessing to go up river.
And I'm like,
okay,
what does that mean?
He's like,
come to the Maloca,
which is the like spiritual house.
So we go to the spiritual house,
we sit around and we talk and we talk and we talk and it's like hours of not
like asking him to go,
but just like almost like idle conversation where he's almost like interviewing
us like,
well,
what are you doing?
Where are you going?
Where are you from?
And he doesn't really understand any of this,
right?
He's like,
he's living in this community.
Long story short,
he goes,
okay,
you can go,
but you have to take this blessing.
And we're like,
sure,
we'll whatever you need for us to go.
So he pulls out the snail shell.
I could show you a picture of it.
It's a snail shell with a monkey bone and the top and a tube worm to close it.
And in this snail,
Shell is the green powder and he's like,
this is what you need for the blessing.
So he goes around the circle and threw a monkey bone pipe.
He blows this green stuff and your nose is it called the [inaudible] not
[inaudible] word that we heard.
I couldn't tell the name of the pipe.
No,
no.
The stuff they blow up your nose is a DMT.
It's coca leaf.
Oh.
Mixed with a bunch of a root and tobacco I believe like altogether.
And um,
anyway,
so he goes,
there's five of us in my crew.
He goes around the circle and he hits three guys and they all go,
whoa.
My brain feels like I've got chlorine on the head.
You know,
whatever loads it into your nose.
Yeah.
So it gets really close.
It's got this long tubular monkey bone pipe and he goes and it just blows it up
into your nose and a hits.
Three of my guys and I'm watching a little bit nervous cause like I'm very like
standoffish on drugs.
Like I know things affect me very strangely.
Anyway,
hits three of my guys,
they go whoa,
you know,
eyes watering and they're like,
wow,
it's a,
it's actually a great feeling.
Gets to my turn
in the nose.
All of a sudden I feel like I've got acid on my brain,
like chlorine in my head.
I break into the sweat,
my eyes explode and I'm like wobbling like this and it 30 seconds later I'm just
curled over in the fetal position,
just projectile vomiting cannot hold it together.
And uh,
Lorenzo,
this,
the,
the tribal shaman goes good,
good.
And we're like,
why is this good?
And he's like,
he had a bad spirit in him.
If he had gone up the river,
he would have been killed.
He's just got the bad spirit out.
This is why I had to bless you.
Now you can go.
And I was the only one that had hit like that out of our five person crew.
Everybody else was like,
oh my brain sore,
whatever.
I was literally fetal position,
feverish,
puking cray.
And I've,
I've never done any drugs like hard drugs.
Like it's just not my thing.
And this thing just hit me like a ton of bricks after he said that.
Did you think was there a po?
I mean you're a scientist,
you're a very smart
guy,
but was there a part of you that was like,
man,
he's this guy,
right?
Yes.
That's what's so crazy.
Cause I'm a fucking scientist.
I don't want to believe that.
I don't want to believe fucking jungle medicine made me not die.
But this guy,
here I am,
nobody else fucking affected.
I'm sitting in the fetal position,
puking my brains out and the guy's going good.
Now you'll be safe.
And the whole fucking trip,
I've got that in the back of my mind going,
maybe the whole reason nothing's going wrong is because I just had green fucking
powder bloat up my nose.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Super Weird.
And I,
nothing has ever affected me like that.
I mean curled up puking now was shivering.
Well you trying to make logical sense out of this.
We try it.
Was there ever a thought we were like maybe in this extreme environment that's
so utterly different than any other place in the world that these rules are
different?
Absolutely.
I mean I,
I'm sitting there going,
going into it.
I'm like,
cool,
yeah,
I'll do this stupid powder.
If it means I can go on my expedition.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not like embracing it.
I'm just like going through the motion to get my job done as a scientist.
And then I had this experience,
and I'm not saying I was enlightened or a woken or anything like that,
but all of a sudden I attributed my success and my safety in small part to this
green fucking powder blown up my nose by a shaman throw a monkey bump.
And the thing about it is,
even if that's not true,
if you think it's true and then you wind up being okay and you have confidence
that you're going to be okay and maybe you have less anxiety and make better
critical decisions because you think that everything's going to work out.
Exactly.
Totally.
Because I was super focused on my mission,
uh,
we,
we were very,
very successful in what we set out to do.
And I,
I feel like because I had that crazy experience and here's this old little
jungle Indian going,
now you're now you're going to be okay.
I didn't have any anxiety going into the situation and before that I had no
thought of it ever playing apart.
Well like the mind fuck of the placebo effect.
Right?
Totally.
We know that that's real.
So there's a some sort of a physical effect by believing that something works.
Right.
But is there a physical,
is there a change in the way you interface with reality,
if you believe that you've experienced some sort of spiritual enrichening and
then some sort of,
uh,
some bad spirit has been released from your body?
Is that possible?
I think so.
I think it changes your own reality because of your perception of the outside
world.
That is a freaky thing for a scientist to say.
Right?
And,
and this is like,
I am a hardcore academic,
I've never considered spirituality,
religion,
anything.
And I had this just fucking 10 days ago this crazy experience that has like
changed my mindset on,
uh,
on crazy jungle medicine and drugs and catching animals,
everything.
Because this one guy blew crap up my nose and I puked everywhere.
Wow.
Now,
has this made you want to experiment with other medicines?
No,
the only reason I did that is because it was a necessity to do what I was doing.
It was coming from an expert,
if you will,
but a person who saw it as a necessity to do what I was doing and I was under
his guidance to go out and,
you know,
pick a mushroom and try it and have an experience is I don't,
I don't see the benefit in that.
But when someone who lives in that community embraces that wild jungle says,
this is my home and this is how you do it,
absolutely do it.
So you do it like out of respect.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Um,
what if they wanted you out of respect?
There's a bunch of those different snuffs that they pump up their nose and one
of them is a,
I think it's,
it's some form of five methoxy dimethyltryptamine,
which is the stuff that comes off a toads.
Oh,
Gotcha.
Yep.
There's,
there's uh,
and it has a bunch of other stuff in it too.
And they do the same thing.
That's why I think that one's called a coup.
Hey,
okay.
I'm not a,
I've read it so I don't know if I'm saying that right.
That must be a hallucinogenic,
right?
Yeah.
They blow it up your nose and you,
you see Jesus.
I mean,
look,
if it was the same situation where he's telling me you got to do this to go to
work,
do your job,
whatever.
Absolutely I do.
And how to respect when you yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think you kind of have to totally be an asshole.
I mean w w I think,
you know,
when you're in the world of these people and they've,
they,
they've survived in this world for eons and this is their environment and like
you kind of kind of have to let go and give in to this.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You have to embrace it.
Mm Man.
Did you live a fucking cool life?
It's weird.
It's really cool.
That's really cool.
Well,
thank you for coming here,
man,
and sharing this stuff with us and thanks for doing what you do.
It's fucking awesome.
I love it.
It's been an absolute pleasure.
I've really enjoyed it.
Yeah.
Anytime.
Sweaty,
thinking about all the shit.
Uh,
tell people how to get ahold of you on Instagram and Twitter and all that jazz.
Yup.
Uh,
I'm my name,
Forest Glen,
t.
F.
O.
R r e.
S.
T,
Goliath Jay.
I'm on all the social media platforms as it forest dot Galante on Instagram,
Instagram on the others.
There's no dot.
Um,
look me up.
Love chatting to people and,
uh,
thank you.
Thank you again.
My pleasure,
man.
Was really fun.
Thank you.
Okay.